We're,
we're about as lucky as human beings
ever get to be.
Do,
do,
do I,
we live body wise,
we're live on podcast wise.
Greg and I were just talking about Greg
for people don't know Greg Fitzsimmons
and I have been friends for like 28
years,
28 years to roll his fucking God damn
fucked.
We started out as raw open.
Miker is almost exactly at the same
time.
Yeah,
but I was dreaming about it since I was
a kid.
When did you,
when did you think that it might be
something you want to do?
Because I was grabbing microphones when
I was fucking eight telling jokes into
them.
No Shit.
That's awesome.
Oh Man.
It wasn't until I was like 21,
like right before I did it,
like maybe 20 or 21 and one of the
reasons for it is a,
a guy still a good friend of mine.
His name's Steve Graham.
He was an ophthalmologist and he was
this guy who was just this.
He's such a fucking wild man.
Like I've met some people that purport,
they look sort of pretend to be wildman.
This guy is the wildest dude I've ever
met my life.
Put a super smart,
super nice guy.
And he was on the US ski team.
Okay.
And when he described his key run that
he did to make the team,
he said like at any moment in time I
would have crashed at any single,
just like I barely hung on the whole way
and had this ridiculous time that I
could never do again.
And he was like laughing about it.
But dude had like,
I'm gonna fuck this up Steve,
you hear this?
I think he had 25 knee surgeries on his
knees.
His knees were insane.
Yeah.
His knees got to the point where they
had to resurface them.
So the top of his knees,
he doesn't have any cartilage anymore.
So there's a steel cap that they put on
the top of his knees and then there's
like this artificial meniscus in there
and it rolls up and down and he has like
a very limited range of motion with his
knees.
He's in his man.
I want to say he probably has 60.
He's still spars all the time.
He's almost legally blind,
like he has to have,
like he's been hitting the head so many
times.
He has to have these,
uh,
these things that go over his glasses so
he could see better because he said a
bunch of ice surgeries hitting the head
from skiing,
from sparring.
He's still spars all the time.
He's super fucking smart,
but he doesn't care.
Like he's like,
he goes on my hair for a long time.
Just here for a good time.
He'll laugh at you.
Like he used to be a flight surgeon.
He's a fucking amnesty from a,
I think he was originally from upstate
New York.
He's one of the very few people that
told me a Ufo story and I had to go,
whoa,
because this dude just doesn't make shit
up.
And he's done everything maniac.
When I met him,
he was a learning taekwondo.
Immediately became obsessed,
want to start fighting immediately while
he was a resident.
Okay.
It was going through his residency for
ophthalmology,
be sitting on the toilet.
He told me sitting on the toilet,
eating lunch,
and as he fell asleep while I was taking
a shit and his pager went off,
will come up.
That's the guy you want to head to the
operating room when you're laying on the
table.
He's a student guys.
GotTa fucking Dukie and his cheeks.
He has enough time to wipe it out.
You were always on call.
You're always working,
man.
I had two friends that went through the
residency.
My other friend was a Korean friend.
His name was junk and junk.
Sick.
He actually won the nationals.
He won the US national championship
while he was in medical school.
Taekwondo,
yeah.
Wow.
He was a beast and he was never like a
really physically talented guy.
He was just unbelievably determined and
super smart and not.
It's not that he was physically inept,
but he didn't have any amazing
attributes like sign.
Some fighters just have amazing physical
attributes.
Plus he could always.
He could already count to 10 in Korean,
so he was like ahead of the class.
He was also like super humble.
It was really weird.
I mean,
you were talking about a dude who won
the national championship and when you
would ask him about it,
he would always say,
oh my God,
I Suck a fucking terrible.
I can't even believe that I win these
fights.
Like who would just joke around about
it?
How do people,
I mean you're,
I put you in this category is I'm amazed
by some people's energy because I've
always had,
I think as I have depression,
I have mild depression,
medicated for it and my whole life I've
struggled to manage my energy and to
focus it and pick what I,
what it is I need to accomplish and put
my energy on that and let go of the
things that keep it simple.
Just keep it simple and I look at
somebody like,
you are talking about this guy and I
mean you already did a three hour
fucking podcast today.
You're sitting down with me.
We're,
we're seven minutes into another three
hour podcasts.
You probably already worked out today.
No,
I didn't.
I think I had a food poisoning.
Oh,
right,
right.
I was telling you before,
but it's just amazing to me how we're
all built differently and when you gain,
when you gauge success,
it's like,
you know,
we all are dealing with a different tool
belts.
Some of us have this unlimited energy
and focus.
Some have adhd and somehow those things
that fuck you up can make you stronger.
Like I'm sure this things about you that
are did maybe you didn't do well in
school because of that made you
successful in life.
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
I'm,
I'm not,
I've never been a very disciplined
person,
believe it or not,
but you've always had the energy.
But I've always been driven,
like I find things that obsess on and
then it's not a discipline thing.
It's a matter of like almost like
limiting my amount of time that I'm
doing them.
Like when I,
like when I was doing taekwondo,
when I was competing,
who was never an issue of I got to be
disciplined and show up to train.
It was the opposite.
It was like I was training all day.
I was constantly training.
I was obsessed,
you know,
so,
but the problem is like if you say,
hey,
you have to go do your taxes,
I'm like,
oh my God,
I can't do it.
It's like if you told me that I had to
be an accountant,
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm too stupid.
I can't do it.
I just don't.
I can't focus on anything I don't want
to focus on.
Getting a business manager was like the
greatest thing that ever happened.
That's huge.
It's also like
picking something for a living that you
actually enjoy doing.
I think there's a lot of people that are
tortured out there that really are
supposed to be like a bike maker.
They're supposed to make fucking
motorcycles or something,
but instead they got sucked into some
insurance job and they don't give a fuck
about it and they're just trying to sell
policies and it's just a grind on your
soul every day.
You and I,
that's what we talking about before the
podcast,
how lucky we are at all,
all these years that we've known each
other like we were fucking common.
Yeah,
this is what we always wanted,
but we didn't even know we wanted this
and it's and when I go,
like people say to me,
I'll be out to dinner.
It'll be like 10,
15 at night.
I'm in Venice beach and with good
friends and my wife having a nice meal,
finishing up some Tiramisu,
pay the bill.
Oh my God.
I'm tired.
All right,
we're going to go to bed.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm heading in Hollywood and do a spot
and about 45 minutes they look at me
like I'm fucking crazy.
And they go,
is it for the money?
I go,
no,
I think I'm getting $15.
Well,
is it to get seen?
I'm like,
there hasn't been industry at the comedy
store in about three decades doing it.
Why you doing it?
And I go,
I got no fucking idea.
I just need to do because I just,
I fucking love it.
And it's not.
And it's like,
and I've never too tired to go do a
spot.
I'll be too tired to write a SPEC script
I was supposed to be working on or
whatever.
But when it comes time to fucking,
I look at my,
my,
my phone and I go,
oh fuck,
I gotta I gotTa Ten 30 at the laugh
factory.
I'm like,
I'm in the car.
I got fucking classic rock plan.
I'm ready to go.
Right?
Yeah.
That makes sense,
man.
You know,
after 28 years,
how lucky are we?
Stupid.
Lucky.
But that energy that you get out of like
laughter people laughing at your ideas
and,
and orchestrating those ideas and
getting them done and you know,
dismounting strong.
Thank you.
Goodnight.
Bring up the next guy.
Especially the way we do it at the store
when you're doing this 15 minute sets,
it's fun.
Math 15 is such a perfect amount of time
working on some new shit.
You do some shit,
you know was going to work.
Work at some new shit.
Yeah.
Taking a little hand or gay hand
grenade.
You know you got.
Yeah.
I,
I a bought a joke.
Just bombed.
Here's a little fucking little thing
called winter jacket from 1987 back in
the game.
And also you get to see all these other
people.
You know.
I think it's super important in this,
in this climate right now.
I'm sure you've been aware of all the
Amy Schumer.
Controversial al.
Please look,
jesus,
we are,
we are all influenced by each other,
all of us.
But it's a good thing.
What's imPortant is just originality.
It's very important.
so what,
like there's comics,
like I know norton doesn't even like to
watch people.
I can't watch people.
Yeah,
he does,
but I do,
I do all the time.
You don't watch people.
Like if luke shows up,
you don't watch them.
I'll watch a little bit and then I'll
walk out.
I tell I can't be anywhere near.
Oh,
he gets you with that cadence.
My balls smell like a fart.
So yeah.
And that's how,
that's how she ended up anyway,
a couple of nuggets later.
You know,
it's like where do I don't say that,
what the fuck.
He's Just too and too strong.
But um,
if I'm working on the road,
I'll watch both comics that the opener
and the m and the feature act.
I'll watch them,
number one.
so I don't do any of the same premises.
And number two,
I feel like I owe it to them because a
lot of them will say,
you know,
I asked to work with you three months
ago,
it's like,
it's a really big deal to them to work
with headliners that they like,
you know,
and I think part of that is I have
responsibility to watch their act and
say,
hey,
great job or you know,
here you go.
You know what I mean?
But like give them,
give them some feedback and fuck man,
I take numbers all the time.
I'll get a guy's number if he's good.
And then when I'm in,
went in his neck of the woods and I'll
call them up and I'll have a feature for
me and in a club that's huge.
That's giant when you're a young guy and
somebody gives you that nod,
like that.
Yeah.
First person I ever worked for was
warren mcdonald.
Yeah.
Bill mcdonald's brother.
He played guitar.
Great guy.
George mcdonald's,
mcdonald's bill,
my brother bill to know george.
It was,
I think they had a bunch of kids in the
family,
but those were the two comedian george
was the one.
I'm sorry,
George George was the one who used a.
George is the one that used to host open
mic night.
First guy to ever Bring me on stage and
an open mike night.
Super great guy.
Greg.
He was my roommate for a while.
Is he really in New York?
We lived on mulberry street together.
Oh dude.
I remember when you lived in little
Italy.
Yeah.
I went to visit you up there once you
have this cool fucking apartment,
like right over an italian restaurant or
something,
and it was.
It was above the raven night social
club,
which was john god,
he's social club.
Do you were in the hood when I went to
visit you when I went up to your
apartment.
I'm like,
dude,
you're in the hood.
Yeah,
it was mulberry between prince and
spring and it was like a,
you know,
wednesdays was,
uh,
was the night when the family would get
together and god,
his son was out front and all these
limos would pull up and they double park
and these guys in overcoats would go out
and they'd go onto this little fucking
club.
Oh my god.
They'd Walk up and down the street
because they,
uh,
the place was wiretapped the raven night
social club was,
um,
where all the deals went down for the,
there's the gambinos right,
got it.
Yeah.
And so they started walking.
They knew the place was wire tapped so
they would walk down the street down
mulberry street in groups and they talk.
So the fbi started inserting,
they would park cars on the street and
they'd put wire taps in the hubcaps of
the cars.
Whoa.
And they would pick up the conversation
as they walked up and down the street.
Yeah.
And so we moved into this place and it
was a tony and gladys.
It was a six floor walk up.
No fucking joke.
And so if you're on the sixth floor,
you have to carry your couch six while
we didn't have to because we moved in
and we took,
they gave us what their part is,
all italian couple and we move in and
they uh,
they had uh,
it was an illegal sublet.
So we move in and they've got the
fucking couches with the plastic on them
and the little end tables.
There's craIg's barrett is,
that's my fucking apartment.
What floor were you on?
Sixth floor.
Oh shit.
Oh no,
I guess it's five.
Five floors.
So you didn't have an elevator.
You had to walk all the way out so fast
and there was no buzzer.
So you'd go out on the fire escape and
throw the keys down below.
That's hilarious.
So someone would ring your doorbell.
Yo.
Hey,
here's the key.
You don't have to drop it on their head.
Right?
But how many times did the key like hit
the ground?
I think after a while it wouldn't be.
You put it in a Sock dude be rolling up
is the move.
I love it.
Yeah.
And it's,
we want to live there for like a day,
let me tell you,
it was,
we move in and so we got all this
plastic furniture and then uh,
and it had a,
the,
the end table.
I open it up and there's um,
shell casings,
shell casings from a gun ho.
And then there was a wire to do was uh,
uh,
a device to listen to record your phone
conversations they'd left behind,
like they were all somewhat in the
mafia.
They weren't necessarily getting paid,
but like everybody was like running
numbers with their friends and involved.
And he goes,
anybody ever bothers you?
You let this guy is like 80 years old.
You let me know,
I'll take care of it.
I know people,
you know who I'm talking,
I'm not going to say I'm talking about,
but you know who I'm talking about.
And so they got a condo around the
corner because their son gregory was in
construction and he bought them a condo
cash.
That was nice.
And then we paid.
We paid $700 a month in rent.
Me and george together first of the
month,
walk around the corner to prince street,
sit down with them,
they'd make cappuccIno,
give us ken ali's and I'd give them $500
cash and then tony would go iN the other
room and I'd give gladys and other 200
because that was her bingo money because
saint saint st anthony's on sullivan
street had been on tuesday nights and
then st patrick's on mulberry street had
bingo on thursday nights.
Was that a deal that you all worked out
together or do you just let us made the
deal the deal,
so to glass,
tell you to keep it on the dl that she's
getting the to.
Tony had no idea.
He told me don't need to know about my
bingo money.
I was so behind me to keep that secret.
What?
Gladys.
I'll go to the grave with the secret
yet.
So they'd all play bingo and then they
bet the numbers.
There was a,
there was a woman,
gina,
and she had these two little schnauzer
dogs and she'd walk up and down mulberry
street and people would stop and say hi
to her.
Like every half a block because she ran
the numbers and you gave her 10 bucks
and I don't know if you know how the
numbers work,
but they basically take the purse
aqueduct every day you'd look in the New
York post and it's,
there's a purse that's like however much
money was bet.
Say It's,
you know,
300,000 5:51 and the last three digits
of the purse is
what the number is that one the day
before.
So you play three numbers for $10 and it
pays w,
w,
w what would the odds be?
Tend to 100 to one.
I don't know what the odds are,
but at this fucking old lady walking
around,
she'd go to the shark bar.
People make bets with her.
My grandmother went to jail for that.
No shit.
Yeah.
Really?
When we would go visit her in jersey,
newark.
Wow.
We'd go visit her for six months.
We'd be like,
where's grandma?
Oh,
grandma's grandma's with your aunt.
Your aunt in there too?
No,
no,
no.
She wasn't.
And it was just,
they were telling me that she was
visiting my ai,
so the,
like on the street corner,
running numbers,
I don't know,
the full extent the store would out
shoot when she said um,
and the,
the,
she wouldn't rat out the mob.
Right.
And that's why they put her in the.
Gave her the option to tell on whoever
her boss was.
Yeah.
She was like,
I'm fuck you.
I'll do time.
So she was in the pokey for six months I
think,
and she was knitting sweaters for the
guards and shit.
And she was my grandma.
I mean she was a full on grandma at the
time.
She would make spaghetti.
She'd make homemade pasta.
Oh my god.
It was incredible to this chapter.
One of your memoir,
right?
They're homemade pasta was incredible.
It was incredible.
Oh,
so good.
Like you would never have anythIng like
he goes,
so like old country hardy mean she
always made her own pasta.
She first generation,
fIrst generation.
What's her last name?
digerlando.
Well that was my grandfather's last
name.
Her last name was spumoni,
I believe it was damn bemoan bangalore.
They were straight off the boat.
They both came here as children.
Fuck that name up.
Come on.
That side of mY family,
I don't really have that much contact
with them.
But um,
my grandmother,
she had an aneurysm.
They gave her 72 hours to live and she
lived for 12 years and my grandfather
never,
never ever.
She was a mess.
She got dementia from it.
She was just gone.
She was paralyzed.
How jesus really,
my grandfather had a totally take care
of her 12 years.
She was like,
my grandfather had to take care of every
single thing she did.
He had a wiper.
He had a clean her.
He had to take care of her bedsores.
Could she move?
Barely make noises and stuff and
sometimes.
Oh dude,
you don't know.
So I,
I lived with them for awhile when I
moved from boston to New York,
when I got signed by sussman and I got a
manager,
I was like,
oh my god,
I've got to move to New York.
I couldn't afford anything.
I definitely couldn't afford to live
anywhere.
And so my grandfather said that I could
stay with them for awhile.
So newark in newark on north ninth
street.
It's the fucking the like.
It's a bad neighborhood.
Like my grandparents live in a bad
neighborhood.
Yeah,
it was a good neighborhood at one point
in time was an all italian neighborhood
and you know,
did a thing called blockbusting when
they move in and say,
hey,
I'm black people moving into your
neighborhood.
You have to seLl now.
Are you going to lose all your money?
Right.
Some people would just sell their houses
left and right.
And everybody moved down and it became a
black neighborhood.
But my grandfather was like,
I like black people who gives a fuck get
off my lawn.
It's like it was his house.
He was never getting rid of that house.
And my grandmother had this aneurysm and
she lived and she lived in agony.
And so when I was staying with them when
I was,
when I moved to New York and I didn't
have an apartment for three months,
I stayed with them and she would just
moan,
make these horrible bones and be like,
god damn it.
She realized what it's like when your
body fails.
You still alive for years and years.
It was all my threshold for pull.
The plug is really,
really high.
Low.
It's low.
Yeah.
If I get anywhere near that state,
take me out.
You know,
just died.
The angel of death.
Remember that guy?
He worked in a nursing home and he
killed 37 people over like three decades
do.
And he would,
people that like your grandmother that
we're suffering,
he would just fucking take them out.
If people knew and they started bringing
them into that place,
I would.
Well,
the question is like,
did he do it to people that weren't
going to die?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
For a goof.
I think in his mind he was doing it for
a good reason.
The angel in,
you know,
he was an angel,
which I could see.
I have my friend johnny come visit me.
He came to visit me in New Jersey and
we're hanging out.
My grandfather just sitting around
talking to them and old linoleum floor,
you know,
the whole house smells like boiled
potatoes.
Fuck fucking salami hanging around all
over the place,
like the whole deal.
Always bought fresh bread every day.
Walked down to the bakery,
got the bread,
came back,
was lIke as a talent as occurrence and
while we're hanging out there and my
grandmother was just moaning in the
other room and my grandpa,
my friend john,
he was like,
holy shit.
I was like,
I told you.
He was like,
dude,
that's negative.
That's what he say to me.
It was like,
dude,
he goes negative.
It is.
It's like the opposite of a sound
machine that cheers you up.
Well,
that's what he was.
He was,
he was my frIend.
Johnny was brilliant,
brilliant guy and just in a weird,
crazy way.
But um,
he,
he was like,
dude,
you don't want to be around that.
Like this is negative for you.
You can't fix it.
Can't fix it.
You gotta get outta here.
Right?
And I was like,
you're right,
your grandfather must have been fucking
psyched that you're staying there for a
little while.
He was fOr awhile.
You know,
he liked it.
He's.
He was a great guy.
He was just such a.
The big thing around the family was
always like,
there was pride that he worked in a
machine shop that made a part for the
nuclear bomb and everybody would say,
hey,
you know what grandpa does,
right?
What grandpa did,
he made something.
He worked inside.
He was like a form and after awhile
worked in some sort of machine shop.
You know what he does?
He kills jabs.
That's what he does.
Fucking three times.
They used his part.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Yeah.
There was like thing people would talk
about maybe three times to two pumps to
two bumps too.
Yeah.
There was like a big source of pride.
I reMember when I was a kid,
I was like,
wow,
that's awesome.
Pretty cool.
No,
that I was in st louis,
st louis.
Now we're have.
Forget we're in Missouri.
Truman is buried,
but they've got a,
his,
his library like his museum and there's
a fucking monument to the bomb outfront
jesus christ.
like this fucking guy had the balls.
We played,
um,
oppenheimer in the last podcast with sam
harris for dan harris from abc news.
He had never heard that oppenheimer
quote when he quotes the bhagavad gita
after the bomb went off.
Now what did he say?
He says,
behold,
I am become death destroyer of worlds.
It's so creepy when you hear oppenheimer
say I play it,
but we played it in the last podcast
when people be like,
what the fuck?
Rogan,
I'll play for you after it's over
though.
It'S creepy because you see his face
like,
this is the guy that made the fucking
bomb.
Yeah.
ThAt's his reaction to read some
sanskrit bhagavad gita quote about
vishnu.
So where did that come from?
Because usually it's like the christian,
the christians that believe in the,
uh,
the second coming or into that kind of
shit.
But that eastern,
either I don't think of eastern religion
is being like that.
well,
he was.
Oppenheimer was a fucking phenomenally
intelligent guy.
he was really looking at sam microscopes
or something.
He created the nuclear bomb.
I don't know what he did before that,
but he was one of the main people.
There's a team of people,
obviously the manhattan project,
but um,
he,
he was,
uh,
just a,
a super genius guy that sam harris was
saying,
we need to double check if that's true.
But sam harris was st last podcast that
he taught himself sanskrit in three
months,
or was it dan harrison said that?
I don't remember who said it is,
but that's how,
that's how,
like what you were talking about earlier
about energy,
an energy.
Think about how fucking stupid we are
compared to that.
Dude.
There's levels to this thing.
you know,
like chrom alone is always going to be
better at basketball than you and me.
There's just no,
there's no matter what we did.
You got to want it more fitzsimmons.
Yeah.
There's,
this is not fair.
It's not fair to seven foot super
athletes.
It's just,
it's not fair.
I know.
It's like when I'm around people that
have perfect memories,
I feel so less than.
And I have to remind myself,
that's just the fucking machine that
this dude was given.
You know,
some hot rod like patton oswald.
There's somebody,
he'll be on stage riffing.
F goes from a fucking tom waits lyric
into like a movie reference of judy
garland,
quote from the 19 four and you just sit
in a gun like I have to look at a list
to remember my act every night.
Yeah.
Mother fucker.
He's a fucking genius.
Verily that's amazing is not only does
he have this photographic memory,
but he distills thoughts in a very
unique way.
Like when he puts up,
I don't read many people's twitters,
but I read his and it's like,
it's always on point and it's always
different than what anybody else is
thinking.
Did you see the tweet that he made?
He made like the best tweet.
Um,
fuck.
What was,
what was it about?
I got to remember this.
And he's also got lImitless energy.
Yeah.
It was about someone showing up at
someone's doorstep to.
Oh,
it was about jamie kilstein was about
jamie kilstein showing up at milo
yiannopoulos his house and cue the theme
music to the odd couple,
like he got kicked out of his,
uh,
his podcast.
It's just his sense of humor,
man.
He,
his,
his premises,
he'll take premises that I would have
abandoned long ago and turned them into
genius bits and stretch them out.
Like I hear some of his stuff on go,
wow.
I just need to like,
focus on topics more sometimes.
Maybe instead of just looking for a
strong topic,
like any topic can be strong if you do
it the right way.
And he figured out,
yeah.
Have you ever heard his fucking bit?
He does about taking his daughter to
starbucks after she had seen the lion
king and there's a black guy,
an old old black guy with white hair and
the daughter yells out,
daddy,
it's a monkey
and this is the way he describes the
place.
It's a coffee shop in silver lake.
And he said,
he said you could barely hear the nora
jones album over the sound of people's
eyes roll.
I think it's such a good,
it's written,
it's a really funny bit about him,
like just running out of there with his
daughter and hashtag racist.
It's really fucking funny.
But tHat's,
you know,
he just
no writing jokes.
I've been,
I've been in a little bit of a slump
lately.
I think mostly because I'm putting
another hour together so I've just been
focused on taking the last two or three
years material,
transitioning it,
tightening it up and so I haven't been
writing new stuff and then when I go
back to writing new stuff,
I'm like,
how does comedy work again?
Yeah,
I think it's okay.
Cop out that we do when we're working on
stuff that we don't do new stuff.
New stuff.
Yeah.
You lose that muscle,
whatever the fuck that weird muscle is.
I just forget like when you really.
I mean if you really want to get into
joke writing,
Breaking it down.
It's like what you said,
do you take the low hanging fruit?
You know,
that there's always that thing that
happens.
You know,
there's that moment where you go,
oh,
that's a fucking joke.
You know?
Like I,
I just bid about my,
I'm driving home,
my wife,
uh,
my wIfe texts me what time I going to be
home,
so I write 6:00 and she says,
will you bring home some eggs?
So I wrote,
sure.
And then I wrote what are you wearing?
And then I got a text back,
my cleats in my soccer uniform and I
realized my wife is driving,
son has her phone and then I got a text
right after that,
why,
what are you wearing?
And I was just like,
alrIght,
I don't have to write anything there.
There's a fucking perfect is a funny
bit.
And then I realized like I didn't take
that,
I've been doing that bit for a year and
I haven't pushed it.
And like bill burr saw me do a bit one
night and he's like,
dude,
what are you doing?
You got fucking,
you gotta fucking unbelievable premise.
Say you gotta fuck it.
And he,
he,
he like riffs like five other beats to
the bit that I do now.
And you just realized like,
yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not fucking pushing it as far as I
can push it.
Do you think that's an energy thing?
Like what you were talking about before?
I think it's a confidence thing.
I think it's having the confidence to
say there's more to this,
I'm capable of getting more out of this
instead of just going like,
okay,
now let me quick get something else
that's going to get an immediate laugh
and jumped topics.
Right,
right,
right.
Which is a hallmark of someone who's
inexperienced or working on completely
new stuff.
Right?
Yeah.
When someone's inexperienced,
like when you watch open microbes,
it's like one of the biggest things that
they do.
And also conversely that the right way
to use it.
Uh,
richard jenny,
who's one of my all time favorites and
stretching out stuff.
Do you ever tell people about this?
I've been telling them as comics,
go download a big steaming pile of me.
Yeah.
The steamIng pile of me or a big
steaming pile of me,
whatever,
whatever the name of it is.
It's richard,
jenny,
one of richard jenny's last specials
before he,
um,
unfortunately killed himself.
But god damn.
Is it good?
Yeah.
So good dude.
I was on the highway coming home from
the store on the highway.
How ling laughing at this special.
Yeah.
And the only reason why I listened to it
is,
you know,
that weird thing your phone does if you
bluetooth your phone,
your car.
Sometimes on my car I'll just start
playing random songs.
Oh really?
Just randomly.
Yeah.
I completely randomly like it just,
it just starts playing like I don't even
press play.
I get the car,
start the car and when I did it,
there was a song,
the song went off and then the next
thing was a richard jeni bit and I was
fucking house and it was so funny.
Yeah,
it was so fun.
And not only that you are losing a lot
of it because seeing that guy live,
he fucking glided around the stage.
He physic because he was a little guy
and so he appeared.
You'd see him after a show and you'd be
like,
you're not the guy that the guy on stage
was six foot one.
You're,
you're five foot Seven.
And what happened to that other guy?
Yeah,
well he dId.
That's special with one of those mc
hammer earpieces holidays.
I'm a motivational speaker.
Things right.
He had one of those on or something.
He had either that or a lav mic,
but he didn't have a mic in his hand,
which I'm always like,
what are you,
what are you transitioning away from
being a stand up and now you're like,
what is that?
He really uses his hands for most people
you don't need that.
But for him it was like,
you know,
he explored physically space.
He accentuated punchlines with movement.
Yeah.
And,
and I would watch him night after night
sometimes,
and if you,
if he was saying the word glo his,
he would,
his weight would be on his left foot.
His right finger would be in the Air and
it'd be the same fucking way the next
night.
It was like a ballet.
It was exact.
He was my opinion the best at taking a
premise and just ringing all the funny
out of it and I remember watching him
and one of the first things that I
realized when I was watching it because
I went to see him,
I paid to see him before ever did stand
up.
And um,
I remember thinking I actually sat in
the front row.
It's pretty bad ass at catch a rising
star in cambridge.
And I remember I saw also saw many
killed there.
I saw kevin,
we were together that night.
I saw him crushed there a couple of
times,
but I saw me and he crushed so hard.
I went with my friend diane from high
school.
We were buddies and we went and it was
like one of the few girlfriends that I
had back then we were just buddies and
she was like a really funny chick and we
went to see kevin meaney and he fucking
killed so hard that I walked out of
there and pain,
like my sides were her.
Like people don't know how hard kevin
meeney used to kill.
I would,
I would put him against in terms of
being in the right room on the right
night.
Nobody killed his heart as kevin media.
He would fucking.
You couldn't kill harder.
You couldn't kill harder because he went
up in this character that was a complete
departure.
It was a silly guy who was joyous and
who didn't give a fuck what you thought.
If a joke started bombing,
he'd start saying,
I don't care.
my jokes don't go over.
And then he start doing it like a dog.
woof,
woof.
He'd be bombing.
The fucking crowd would not be laughing
and he would string that out for like
three minutes until all of a sudden they
just started laughing at this insane man
who was sweating and flopping around on
stage.
Yeah.
Well,
when I saw him,
there was no bombing at all.
It was just destruction.
It was when he had just done hbo and he
was in that group.
He was on fire.
Dude,
it's hard to describe because so much is
lost when you see a guy like that on a
big stage or on television.
Yeah,
you lose like being in the room with
them.
Absolutely.
There was a hypnosis going on when he
would crush.
Yeah,
so It was like him.
I,
I remember seeing him crush like that
and going like god,
like he was like so silly and it was so
fun to get caught up in his silly.
That was one thing that I saw closing
with.
We are the world,
but you took it to another level because
they had some fucking music and a funny
song.
Impressions within the song.
He kept that bit too long.
Way too long now.
That was his downfall.
Was he crushed for a decade?
Five years?
Yeah.
Maybe it was only five years and then he
just wouldn't take the material off.
Yeah,
well he went national and he had the
ethic that the guys in boston had.
That was the problem.
The boston guys did didn't go national,
but they all came up together and he was
one of the top guys and they all came up
doing the same act.
They would tighten that fucking act.
They would hammer down like a samurai
sword and then they would,
they would go all around town with that
same act and they just did that.
There was no social media.
There was no one to complain,
but I did a friends who would complain.
They're like,
jesus christ went to see fucking sweeney
did the same goddamn act I saw last
year.
Yeah,
that's gonna.
You know you're going to get a few of
those this week.
Yeah,
probably.
But meaning that he fucked up.
But you were Steven Wright didn't fuck
up.
steven right left from that spot.
Jay leno left from that spot and they
did new stuff all a route.
yeah.
Yeah.
He just got stuck,
was crazy because I remember watching
him not do well and one time he had to
go on in miami after joey diaz and it
was a disaster.
Joey was yelling out punchlines and
spanish and it was talking about sucking
his dick and all the sudden he was
sweating and people going crazy and it
was just.
They were just going fucking crazy
because joey diaz in miami,
in the cocaine days,
he would kill like you,
you never,
you never seen anything like it before.
There was no fucks left in his brain.
And he was saying,
shit,
that was so ridiculous.
We get all the fucks out.
They were gone.
He didn't give a fuck.
He get,
he had no fucks to give and he's onstage
talking about slinging dick.
And it just,
it was,
it was.
So he was such a caricature and kevin
had a really hard time and kevin had to
go on after him and it was a disaster.
A disaster.
Kevin want to believing and
yeah,
well he,
you know,
he had a lot of chapters to his life,
and then he,
he had a really hard time for a long
time and then he,
then he ended up on broadway doing great
with john pinette in hairspray and then
that ended and uh,
and he came out of the closet while he
was on broadway,
changed his life and he became a happier
person.
Lost weight.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
Fascinating man.
Fascinating.
Different chapters of people's lives,
but like who he was like when um,
you know,
when he went on after joey diaz in miami
should never be confused wIth who
it was when I saw him in boston,
a kia just,
he hit a stride and he wasn't able to
maintain it,
but you can never forget how fucking
good he was.
Is youtube is a tonight show.
Appearance is because carson fucking
loved him.
Carson,
they would cut away to carson.
He didn't have his head on his desk,
pounding it with his fist wiping tears.
I mean he,
he,
and nile and it was just,
it was so bIg you couldn't follow it.
And so he got his break with that show,
which was,
I blame his representation.
He should have never done uncle buck.
It was the wrong fucking show for him
and it.
And it was so high profile and he was so
big that when it failed,
it really crushed him for a long time.
Comics would just extend up.
Yeah.
Whenever we do other shifts,
ones up kid in the way.
Right,
right.
Louis,
he had a great fucking statement the
other night.
He and I were talking backstage is about
gone.
He said it doesn't do anything but stand
up anymore.
He said,
to be your best you have to do.
Just stand up.
He goes,
you can be really good and do other
stuff,
but like you know when you're doing this
tv show and all jazz,
he's like to be your best,
you have to just do stand up so he's not
going to do tv for awhile.
I don't know man.
I mean he could do whatever the fuck you
want,
but one of the things he said,
he's like,
I can be happy doing this forever.
God,
it's inspiring.
You mean getting on a private jet and go
into that because you sent out one tweet
tweet anymore.
He deleted his twitter.
I think the cla,
all the theater just tweet,
like ticketmaster sends out a tweet and
it fucking sells out,
but how smart is that that he recognizes
he's at that stage.
Just steps away from.
But it also takes.
I mean you have to have like I think
some people need to spend a lot of
plates.
Like I,
I can't just do standup because I start
to,
it's not so much bored,
but I just feel like I got to do with
the shit I get claustrophobic.
yeah.
And I just,
I need to go.
Like I,
like right now I'm writing on a show and
I'm fucking loving it.
And I'm taking you run on a pizza right
on pete holmes show.
Chris was talking about before.
Pete holmes is such a good guy.
He's a good dude.
He is.
And he's um,
he's a nice guy.
He's good in the room too.
I mean we're coming up with show ideas
and like,
you know,
there's like seven or eight writers
pitch and shit and they're all talented
writers.
Um,
and then he'll just go like,
um,
he is the best way of saying no.
It's very hard to write a room to run a
room and not make people feel like
they're not heard or they're being
rejected and he's got this energy that's
just like,
yeah,
that's funny.
And what if we did this?
And you sorta like,
he moves on in a way that,
you know,
the idea is not getting used but it
might have triggered something else in
him and we ended up with these episodes
that are just fucking linear and they're
there things that he signed off on and a
lot of times you get somebody running a
writer's room and they,
they get codependent so they'll put shit
the script that they don't even believe
in and between him and judge,
judge in the room a lot between the two
of them in the room.
We got fucking,
we got episodes locked down alreadY.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
there is that weird dynamic between
showrunners and and comics and actors.
And it's such a struggle that everyone
gets,
wants to get their greasy fingers on it,
especially in the beginning or at the
beginning of the shows create like once
you get to like some simpsons level or
it's just like it's just a smooth
machine.
Just they know what the fuck to do.
Leave hIm alone.
Leave most,
stay away from the south park guys.
Just get the fuck out of the way.
You know,
don't,
don't get your greasy fingers in it.
Now if it's a brand new show and also
being an hbo show,
they just give you the keys to go.
All right,
do it lock up when you're done.
There's no,
there's no.
I mean I wasn't there the first season,
but I heard there was very little notes
from hbo.
That's what netflix is kind of doing to
netflix.
Doesn't have any notes why the fucking
shows are good.
No,
I mean,
look,
look at these network multi cameras,
sitcoms.
It's like,
do you ever see the clip where they take
the laugh track out of big bang theory?
I have seen that.
Terrific.
But you know what that is?
That's pickups.
A lot of it.
What do you mean?
You know what pickups are like?
You shoot a scene and then they have to
change a line or they want to do
something different and they do pick up
some episode of big bang theory that
aired and then they sucked out the laugh
track.
So you're seeing these negative.
Definitely.
Oh,
you're seeing silence where normally you
would be laughing in theory if it was
funny,
but they just insert laughs and so I
guess people at home laugh at the same
time because they're triggered to.
Well,
it's might be very.
Yeah,
that's a soundtrack.
Probably a laugh track rather.
The laugh track is.
Yeah,
it's like some kind of uh,
we did shows,
I think there were,
they do,
we didn't even know what audience and
they just,
they did a laugh track on news radio.
Oh yeah,
you guys did it.
We did a couple shows that were like
completely ridiculous.
I can't remember if they used to laugh
track or if they showed it to people.
I think it's some of them they showed it
to people.
I feel like in at least one or two
scenes or mother had a laugh track,
but we did a few episodes that were like
super bizarre.
Like one of them was in space,
so the whole episode took place in
space,
like just news radio in space.
No explanation whatsoever.
A space suit on like the whole thing.
It's fucking ridiculous.
And that deep into season six,
I think,
I don't remember what season,
we only dId five seasons,
but another one we did a titanic
episode.
We will do one ridiculous episode every
now and again.
The titanic episode.
We literally had a fill the setup with
water.
So in the titanic episode mark sloshing
through water up to my waist.
It's freezing or it's fucking cold man,
because like you think of water that you
climb into like unless you're outside
and this is a summer,
it's 100 degrees out there was going to
be fucking cold and you can only stand
it for so long before you start
shivering.
So you're walking through the.
They,
they,
they turned a set.
He'll fucking swimming pool.
So ridiculous.
That's hilarious.
Just paul simms as a genius.
Yeah,
It was just a mad man.
You know,
we should do one night just as an
experiment is set ups a couple speakers
in the back of the room at the comedy
store and do a laugh track during our
set and see if it makes the audience
just fucking go into a frenzy.
Would you think that it wouldn't know
something's amiss?
That would really be funny.
You write a bunch of shit that's
purposely not funny and have some
ridiculous soundtrack.
See how people reacted that way.
There'll be a fascinating experience
experiment.
Rather if you did something super
offensive,
you know,
you talked about something like super
super offensive.
Yeah,
and you did it all under hidden cameras
and you just see if people laughed at
something that's like really fucked up
and then interview them after the show.
Why were you laughing at that?
You know,
like isn't that like the always supposed
to be the knock on shit?
Like when people talk about rape
culture,
they're always supposed to say that you
know,
some guys on stage and he's talking
about rape and everybody's cheering and
laughing like that fucking never
happens.
That never happens.
Like if you go on stage and you have a
joke about rape,
god damn that joke better be funny.
Yeah,
it better be so god damn funny if you're
going to pull off a rape joke.
Oh,
you saying people clapping on the wrong
side of it.
WhAt I'm saying is do a joke that is
purposely offensive,
really
bad,
but do it on purpose.
Let everybody know,
don't let the audience know,
do It in front of the audience and have
a ridiculous soundtrack in the back of
the room,
which is roars,
laughter,
and have people around going,
what the fuck she's talking about raping
kids and have cameras set up to capture
the audience's reaction and then put it
on.
Put it on youtube and interview them
afterwards.
Ask them like if they sign a release,
I have to sound fucking releasing.
what were you thinking?
How would you go?
Like,
are you freaking out that people were
laughing?
Like,
I don't know.
I just started laughing.
Yeah,
couldn't.
I was compelled.
What else is laughing?
That's what happens,
right?
People are laughing.
He around you.
You start laughing more.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean that is,
that's part of the reason why club is so
good because they're all like jammed in
together like that.
Yeah.
No,
it's a weird.
It's a very weird phenomenon when.
Because there's always the guy that
goes,
I should be a comedian because at my
office everybody tells me I'm like the
funniest guy,
and it's like,
well then you know what?
You'd probably be a good comedian
because it's easier on stage in a way.
If it's a good crowd and you go up
there,
you've got 100 people facIng you
drinking that has the here's the,
here's the drill.
You pay,
you pay money and you laugh.
Not you might cry,
you might,
whatever.
No,
there's an agenda.
You're going to laugh,
so if you get up there and you do things
that are in the realm of funny,
you're going to get the benefit of the
doubt more so than if you walked onto a
subway platform and started tellIng a
bunch of rush hour commuters.
The same fucking material.
Yeah.
Or your friends that don't want to hear
you talk over them.
The worst thing is watching one guy go
on a rant that might be funny and the
other guy starts talking over it and
you're like,
oh no.
Yeah,
no.
That that guy's going through right now.
The ranter when he's like in the groove
and the other guys were.
I go to a furniture designer too,
and just shits on his rent.
When you see guys at a bar and what they
want,
guys just starts talking over the other
guy,
the lift on their toes and get louder
and louder.
Yeah,
because there's a chick there and
they're trying to score.
That's the worst.
Did you ever have a friend that would
insult you and girls were around?
Oh yeah.
I had a friend fucking knock me down
once we punch.
Well,
there was an ice,
there was a lake near my house growing
up and we used to skate there.
it was fucking unbelievable.
I grew up in tarrytown,
New York,
and we had this reservoir that actually
feeds New York city.
It's like the main reservoir for the
water drinking water in New York city.
And so,
um,
it would freeze in the winter and then
they had this shack,
this big fucking wooden shack twice the
size of this room and it had benches and
it had a little snack bar,
hot chocolate and hot dogs.
Then you go outside and there's like a
wooden wooden steps going down into the
lake with telephone poles.
They put it,
and this is a big fucking leg telephone
poles around half the circumference of
the,
uh,
the perimeter of the lake with
spotlights and radio,
and they would crank fucking pop music
and you'd go out there until 11:00 at
night.
We'd hide six packs in The snow on the
banks of the lake.
We go out there,
we're in seventh and eighth grade
drinking a couple beers,
hitting on chicks.
And so I'm out there one night and then
during the day we play hockey all
fucking day.
They had metal nets they would put out
and they would use a plow to plow the
snow to make rinks out of the fucking
snow on the ice.
Whoa.
It was insane.
And this was before global warming.
That shit froze by christmas and we were
skating in march every fucking year.
March,
early march.
How do you know when to stop?
Well,
it's three feet thick plate.
How do you know when it's not three
days?
They tell you the town tests it.
There's a big visit,
another shack on top of the hill where
they have spotters.
There's guys that are ringing,
you know,
guys skating with jackets that are the
rink guys.
And um,
so,
so anyway,
I'm there and I'm talking to this chick
from the next town over.
So olin was her name.
I remember this deep voice.
Brown eyes were real fucking italian
girl.
That was my type little plump italian
and I'm talking to her and all the
sudden I get fucking knocked down.
This kid,
chris spencer had skated towards me and
just checked me just fucking.
And I fell down,
hit my head,
couldn't get up for a little bit.
And I was like,
what?
The.
And my friends were laughing.
It's like,
what the fuck was that?
Chris was like trying to break into our
little circle of friends and he was this
big dude and he lifted weights and that
was his way of like getting into the
group was too fucking knock me down.
When I was talking to colin and I tried
to fight him later after when I had my
sneakers on and thankfully somebody
broke it up,
he would've fucking killed me,
but I'm cut to.
Oh,
insulin liked me at the time.
Cut to a.
What was it,
a halloween the following year we're
running around and somebody sprayed
shaving cream in my eyes and so I chased
him down and it was somebody dressed as
a bum,
knock them down,
sitting on top of him,
punching him in the face.
People start grabbing me screaming,
dude,
it's a girl.
So I fucking runaway.
Turns out.
Oh no.
Guess what?
Guess we had a big crush on me.
Now her after you beat her ass,
tell me about her fucking childhood.
Whoa.
Really?
Yeah.
So what happened?
Did you have to apologize now?
I.
She was in the next town so I didn't
really.
I just ducked out of center.
how many times you hit her?
I think a few times.
She's a girl.
WhY did she spray you in the face?
Does she know?
It was,
you know,
he used to run around with.
We would take shaving cream and we put
aerosol tops on a shave down barbasol
can and we'd spray each other.
You know,
when you came
home you were covered.
You were a snowman when you came home
and we'd have eggs and we slap each
other in the Forehead with an egg and
we'd run around.
There's always one asshole had nair and
then you'd have to go home early because
he sPrayed fucking nair on your head.
so she,
she sprayed shaving cream In my eyes.
Couldn't see that.
Well wow.
And I,
uh,
knocked around a little bit.
My first domestic abuse charge her go
punch me on the bus once really was like
weird thing,
man.
When I was 14 I got on the bus for a,
for 13 year olds,
like the junior high school bus.
And there was this guy who actually
became a buddy of mine later.
He was young back then,
mugsy malone and shut the fuck up.
Just a tiny little dude at the time he
was,
I think he's two years younger than me.
And anyway,
some girl was mad at me for something.
I don't remember what happened,
but she started throwing punches at me
and I'm like,
what the fuck?
And I block her punches and then I,
I looked down and the dude was right
behind her and then he said something to
someone else,
said something to him and he looked at
me and goes,
yeah,
I ain't afraid of you either.
And I was like,
all right.
I'm just,
what the fuck ever,
man.
It's like,
can I fight this girl before I fight you
mosey wills?
It's just fucked up.
I was new to the town and I don't know
what happened when she was mad at me
for,
but I remember blocking punches by some
girls trying to beat my ass.
The fuck are you doing?
And this little dude mad at me too.
But bugsy malone,
who is he wearing?
A little newsy cap from the 19 forties.
I'm super lucky.
I never hit that girl back because it
turned out she wound up dating my friend
mark who a captain of the wrestling team
like afterWards,
like after this and he would have killed
me.
He was an aniMal and he was a couple
years old and I was like,
I was 14,
he was 17,
he was a senior and he was like one of
the best wrestlers in the state.
He was an animal.
He smoke cigarettes in between wrestling
practice.
He would be in wrestling practice and
that girl that tried to beat my ass,
she would.
She would open up the door and he would
go outside and it was wintertime out and
he would take a couple of drags of a
cigarette.
ReallY?
Yeah.
While he was wrestling like at a really
high level,
he was smoking cigarettes.
Yeah.
He was like a,
a thug slash athlete.
Interesting.
Like legitimate Bad motherfucker like
animal.
It was an animal wrestler Made me
realize like real early on,
like wrestling practice maDe me realize
like how hard some people work out.
I had no idea how hard some people work
out.
Yeah,
because I had taken like karate classes
before and I had played baseball,
but I never did anything like wrestling
in my first days of rest in class.
I remember thinking,
what the fuck you guys worked this hard.
We have to go upstairs with to carry
someone on our back and climb up stadium
stairs.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Like why?
What we're doing what we're doing.
Endless drills were fireman carrying
each other back and forth across the
fucking gym,
racing each other and constant live
drills with wrestling.
I would leave there.
I could barelY walk.
I was so tired.
I didn't.
I didn't do any homework while I was
wrestling and I just want up doing no
homework ever.
THat's true.
With wrestling you.
It really fucks up your grades.
You come home,
annihilate,
violated your hungry.
But I just want to sleep.
And then did you have to try to lose
weight from her?
I did,
but I wound up stopping doing it because
my friend steven was wrestling at 128
pounds and he was a better wrestler than
me so I went up to 1:34,
which is basically like what I weighed
when I was 14 or 15,
whatever it was.
So it was pretty easy.
I didn't have to cut any weiGht at all,
but then I cut weight for taekwondo when
I stopped wrestling and then I started
fiGhting and taekwondo.
I cut a lot of weight up until I was 17
and then when I was 17 I was still
trying to make 140 pounds,
but I'd be walking around at like 1:50
something and I would just starve myself
and dehydrate myself was terrible,
really fucked with my performance and
then I stopped doing it.
I went up to 1:54 and when I went up to
1:54,
I became way better.
That was when I Got better.
I was holding myself back by the dieting
and I think that that's a big factor
with wrestlers,
but one thing we wrestlers is that their
Mental toughness,
because of that weight cutting,
it's almost worth it because the mental.
It's super bad for your health to cut a
lot of weight,
but those guys who could do it and still
compete,
they have the ability to push through
discomfort and just have a drive to win.
At.
Very few sports can match because very
few sports,
where will the athlete compete in a
state of like uncomfort as much as
wrestlers?
They're just dieting,
starving theMselves,
dehydrating themselves and still going
out there like fucking savages.
So it's just a different kind of sport
man.
Different sport.
But anyway,
that girl basically beat my ass.
I mean she didn't really beat my ass,
but she was younger than you.
I think she was my age.
She was on the bus too.
She was taking the bus back,
but I was thinking I'd better not
punched this girl.
Oh my god.
I'm so glad I didn't.
I got smacked by a gay kid in eighth
grade.
Oh shit.
You got pimp slapped.
Pinch this,
this black kid,
keith.
He was really a feminist and so he used
to tease him.
yeah.
I'm not proud of it.
but like at that age he just kinda did.
It was like,
you know,
I'm embarrassed by it.
Like we,
you know,
I used to whatever,
cock your wrist and say shit.
And he turned around a fucking,
smacked me across the face and I,
and he,
and he stunned me.
I was like,
holy shit.
And uh,
I didn't know what to do because he was,
he was part of a family that was,
there was projects and tarrytown and
there were cousins and there were
families that had a lot of cousins and
his,
his cousins were some bad ass
motherfuckers.
The davis's.
Oh no.
And so,
uh,
this isn't to say I necessarily would
have hit him after that for a number of
reasons,
one of which I was not that touGh.
I was pretty tough with girls,
but,
um,
but I think I was just so shocked.
Did you know that you deserved it?
Do,
do you have a feeling I deserved.
I got hit a lot as a kid and I deserved
it most of the time.
I got punched in the face in time square
when I was about 14 drinking southern
comfort.
I walked past some guy who was like some
fucking homeless drug addict who was
like coughing up a louis.
And so I started coughing really hard to
making fun of him.
He came back and punched me right in the
face.
You don't want to get beat up by a
junkie.
We know you're not in the days of aids.
Oh,
that's rIght.
It was.
Could have been an aids he punched now.
I used to get smacked around.
I was.
I was such a fucking asshole.
I was such a wise ass cause I was the
smallest kid.
So that was how I fit in.
I was the funny guy who made fun of
everybody.
I would pick fights because then my
friends would,
would fight the fights.
I was that guy.
Well certain things that kids like when
they're growing up and one of the big
ones,
just things happening.
We like action.
Like something happened.
If fitz,
he's going to go fuck with that guy,
but I'm going to kick his ass because
we're bored.
We had no fucking internet phones.
We stood on a street corner for five
hours.
That was saturday night.
My friend kenny.
We'll just start fights with people who
would just go find someone like a bus
stop and just start beating him.
No shit.
Come on.
We're fighting.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
watch them fight.
I watched him get his ass kicked.
He did it once with this guy and the guy
knew how to fight.
Guy was beating his ass.
Good.
What's the kids name?
Kenny.
What was his deal?
He was just nuts.
He was older than us.
He was like one,
one or two years older than him.
They guy?
Nope.
Nope,
not particularly big.
Just fucking tough as nails.
He had a boxing tattoo on his arm.
Like I think he had a tasmanian devil
with boxing gloves on.
They didn't really box.
Yeah,
it was just one of those things like
never made it to an actual gym like
maybe a couple of times,
but we just start fights and wasn't
really that good at it.
Yeah,
it was.
It was just crazy.
He just,
he was crazy and he wanted to fight and
he realized that with his limited
mentality and view of the world that the
most fun that he had was when he was
fiGhting.
So it was like,
well that means we fight until he just
would want to fight all the time.
Like one time my dog got hit by a car.
It was really sad,
man.
I lived on a busy street and my dog
opened the door and she gets super
excited to go for a walk and she didn't
ever on a leash and she ran out into the
street.
I just didn't anticipate or running.
She's usually pretty good about it.
And she ran out and she got nailed by a
car.
Geez.
Oh,
so sad.
She died right in front of me.
I carried her back into the house and
she shit herself.
Like that's when I knew something I
didn't,
I still didn't know something was wrong,
but looking back I would've known she
just shit all over the kitchen and I was
like,
I can't believe she shit herself.
Like what?
Like why she never sits in the house.
And um,
then she just slowly slipped away,
just lie down and I'm just stopped
breathinG.
Man just bled blood from the inside
bleeding.
She Got
hit by a volkswagen bug kind of dog.
She was a mix.
She was boxer and I think she had some
german shepherd in her too.
Sweet dog.
Sad shit man.
Who's sad?
Shit.
It was a real bummer man.
It was a real bummer.
But anyway,
uh,
I told kenny I'd never had it.
I mean I'd had dogs die.
we had a dog that we adopted.
It had distemper when one up having to
put it to sleep,
start going crazy.
It was an adult dog,
not Adult,
but it was over a year old and a,
it was a doberman and it just started
barking at us and smiling.
It's its teeth and it just started
losinG its mind and we got it calmed
down enough.
We'd get a leash on it and brought it to
a vet and the vet said it had to stamp
her.
We had to put it down.
So I had had that happen before,
but I've never,
never seen a dog die in front of me.
Sad shit.
So I tell kenny,
he's like,
we're fighting.
That's it.
Come on out with fighting rogan.
You'll fucking fight no excuses tonight.
And we drove around and he like wanted
me to pick fights with people.
I'm like,
dude,
am not fucking fighting anybody.
That's the way he would deal with his
emotions.
Yeah,
pretty sure.
Sadness,
fight,
anger,
fight.
Looking for excitement,
It's an end.
It's also,
there's a thing about,
um,
young guys were young guys always want
to be the crazy one.
Like,
oh,
mike's the fucking craziest.
Mike's fucking crazy,
michael,
and give a fuck.
And it becomes like a social status
among young.
Especially.
We were talking about this beFore the
podcast.
Everybody,
our age was like a latchkey kid.
Everybody our age had a mom and a dad
that worked and they open the fucking
door in the morning and you were off to
the races.
You went school afterschool.
They weren't home for hours,
right?
You did a bunch of shit by yourself.
Most of the time we're around other
fucking savages our age.
So it's the abstract influence of the
parents on the children.
That is really like giving you your
experience for who you are as a young
person.
Yeah.
You're,
you're,
you're experiencing how these people
taught their kids and what the result
was because you're around the kids all
the time and not around your parents.
they say that you're raised by your
peers after the age of 12 year.
Basically your parents are out.
Yeah.
You're raised by your peers.
You're constantly with your friends in
school.
any activities you have.
You're looking for their validation
instead of your parents validate.
Exactly,
and with My friends it was always,
who's the sickest fuck?
Mike's a sick fuck,
you know,
steve's just sick as fuck.
He doesn't give a fuck.
he's crazy and there was a value in that
because everybody was scared.
That waS really at the bottom line of
it.
We're all young men and we're on our way
to becoming adults and no one knows what
the fuck they're going to do and we have
a few friends that have graduated
highschool and they're losers now and
like,
shit,
that might be me.
Like that was the big cloud that was
always hanging over everybody's head.
What are you doing after high school?
And it was like this impending date of
doom that was coming up.
So everybody was scared all the time and
everybody wanted to be.
They wanted to be a man.
Everybody they wanted to prove
themselves.
They wanted it to be somethinG special
and no one felt special.
You know,
everybody felt like fucking loser,
you know,
we're all like waitinG,
waiting to become an adult so you could
get a job like all these other people
you knew that were around you or escape
or figuring out a way to escape he had.
Then there's always the community
colleGe,
like people go,
well,
you know,
I'll probably end up when you hear I'll
probably end up at the community
college.
THat's going to be one semester and out.
I did that.
I went to massbay massbay community
college.
I did it after a whole year.
I took a whole year off and I just,
I only went back to school because I
didn't want people thinking I was a
loser,
so I did like maybe one semester at mass
bay.
I don't even think I finished the
semester and then I left and went to
umass.
Umass boston had this like adult
education program.
we didn't have to have a ged or a not
gad sat because I never took my sats
because when I graduated from high
school I'm like,
I am never going to school again,
like,
fuck this.
But I got so tired of feeling like a
fucking loser.
Like wHen I tell people is take,
I would always say I was taking a year
off,
took a year off,
but it really,
I just had no directioN I was doing was
doing martial arts and competing and I
just was so terrified of what the fuck
the future lead.
And so I went to umass for like three
Years but not like three full years.
It was like there was still a lot of
credits to be acquired if I was going to
graduate and I just was wasting my time.
I was barely paying attention.
I wasn't doing.
I was completely half asking whatever
project we had.
And then I was realizing like,
what am I,
why am I wasting my time?
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
I got some letter saying that I couldn't
come back With the grades that I had
unless I came up with some very
compelling reason.
So they wanted me to make an arguMent
for why they should include me back in
the class.
And I wrote out in handwritten because
back then no one had a fuckin
typewriter,
thiS total bullshit letter,
this ridiculous,
like a persuasive bullshitty letter
about how important education is to me.
And I'm like how important it means.
And then I realized like the amount of
effort that I put writing this bullshit
letter to keep these people from kicking
me out of their school,
which I wasn't paying attention to far
exceeds any effort that I ever put on
any project ever in class.
Yeah.
And then I realized,
Okay,
whatever I'm going to Do with my life,
it's not going to involve doing.
This is not going to involve someone
else dictating my schedule for whatever
reason.
And you're like,
clearly I can write clearly.
I can really think maybe common.
Yeah.
Well,
I had a conversation with,
um,
a science teacher,
the science teacher,
and it was the same kind of thing.
I,
I'm mocked him in class,
not necessarily mocked him,
but I brought up something that was
contrary to what he was teaching.
He was talking about a lake erie being a
dead lake.
And I said,
listen man,
they had a documentary on pbs last night
about lake erie making a resurgence and
these scientists have figured out these
new ways to minimize water pollution and
all this shit.
And like other kIds looking at me like,
what the fuck?
And he got pissed at me.
He got really pissed at me and he said,
you're undermining my class and this is
not a go,
hey man,
you're teaching old shit.
This is on tv man.
This on tv.
Like Yesterday.
Yeah.
And I had a conversation with them
afterwards and because I had to talk to
him in order to get back in the class,
he kicked me out of class and he said
two things.
He said,
one,
he said,
first of all,
I don't know whether or not that was the
case.
Whether or not it's true and if I allow
you to just interrupt my class and chime
in,
something like that and it's not true.
I haven't fact checked it.
You're telling the whole class and I
don't know if you're right or you're
wrong or you're making things up,
but you're interrupting my class.
That's the point.
If you have something to tell me about
it,
maybe you could tell me about it after
the class and then I can go and look it
up and then maybe I can correct the
class he was,
but to in interrupting the class you
showed yourself to be more articulate
and more intelligent the you ever showed
ever in the entire semester.
So you're totally half housing.
Everything you do,
you're writing everything in paper.
You turn in every test you do,
every time I call upon you for a
question totally half that have asked
that,
but when you wanted to correct me on
something,
all of a sudden you knew all the words.
You knew how to form the sentence
correctly.
You've got to say with the right impact.
He's like,
you just.
Your focus is off.
I was like,
god damn,
that dude's on the money,
and I realized.
I'm like,
yeah,
so I'm not stupid,
right?
I just can't.
I can't listen.
I can't do it.
They're way I got to do it my way
could.
I just didn't.
I grew up not having any direction.
So someone doesn't tell you what to do
all your life,
like essentially you just out free.
I would go fishing,
I'd hang out with my friends in the
fucking woods.
We just go find shit to do and then all
of a sudden you're in school and they're
telling you everything you have to do
all day.
Like,
I'm not ready for that.
I'm not really that like you're sitting
in.
I'm fucking shocked.
When my kid tells me about it,
I go,
what was your scheduled today?
Well,
you know,
at eight,
15,
we sat down for 15 minutes for homeroom.
then at 8:30 I go to my first class,
which is an hour and 15 minutes.
Then we get five minutes off and we go
to another class that's two hours.
They got these long fucking class and it
goes like that till 3:00,
thinking like 25 minutes for lunch and
they're sitting be boys with fucking
chemicals racing through their bodies
and girls at the next desk with fucking
short shorts and cleavage and little
brown titties sticking him.
You know when the breeze hits them and
they get a little bit of goosebumps on
the inside of the cleavage and that
cross jesus is just wedge right in
between those two.
Brown for the italian horn,
the italian,
and it's got glitter on it or the
italian.
How about charm bracelets?
Charm bracelets.
The fuckIng flip flops.
Her toes.
She just painted them with toes.
Very important.
The girl doesn't take care of her toes
now.
Can't trust her with a pussy.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
Show me your face.
I hate to do this on equal pay day.
Oh yeah.
No.
You go into the salon.
You're going to get you're gonna.
Get your fucking nails done after you
get your coach done.
Wow.
Very important for greg fitzsimmons.
Yeah.
What'd you the idea of letting those
kids get trapped in that system where
all day you're just doing that and then
you get sitting passively and then you
get out and you have more work to do at
home.
That just sort of eliminated any social
life you might have,
right?
You would think that that would be
enough that going to school from seven
to three eveRy fucking day or whatever.
They made our job.
It's almost like an eight hour job and
then
where you're really working,
the average eight hour job,
you're checking your email half that
time.
The average person that's working,
is that a cubicle?
I talked to people at shows.
I listen to your podcast all the time.
When at work,
what do you do?
You know,
I work in an office insurance,
shouldn't you be selling shirts?
Ah,
you know,
I listen to rogan's podcast everyday.
That's three hours now.
You know,
they're barely working.
Nobody fucking works.
Nobody's working.
Especially if you have any,
any sort of gig with any flexibility,
like it would just be on your own.
You're on your own.
You can get it done in a couple of
hours.
Most you go to europe and a lot of
business models are.
It's a shorter work day.
It's a longer lunch,
more vacations.
They get the same shit done.
You shouldn't have for five days a week
either to be four.
Yeah,
four is good.
Three days off is good.
When Jamie and I do podcasts,
we do more than four days.
I'm like,
what are we doinG?
Working like,
we'll come in on the fifth day.
I'm like,
jesus,
jamie,
what are we working?
Yeah.
Even if it's like a fight companion,
I'm like,
look at us.
We're here again,
back in the fucking office and this is
the greatest job of all time.
Imagine if you're selling insurance,
you know,
or hyundai's.
We're really coming down on an insurance
salesman.
I don't know why.
Attack premise.
It's easy to ship on.
Well,
insurance is an interesting gig because
if you're on the side where you're
writing policies and you're coming up at
the fucking numbers on like.
Because I remember when I was at boston
university,
there was a guy at the entity in the
aDministration that had figured out the
insurance policies,
you can take out insurance policies on
every student in the university,
pay for them,
and then the policies would pay back to
boston university if you die.
There were life insurance policies
because this guy looked at the numbers
and crunch them and he goes,
you know what?
This is a fucking great deal.
You know what?
These kids fucking dIe more often than
the insurance company thinks.
So they literally took out insurance
policies on 30,000 kids.
That's unsaleable back to the university
and it was a big blow up in the
newspaper about it.
I was making jokes when I was like,
yeah,
I was wondering why they took all the
traffic lights and on commonwealth.
Oh,
crazy.
They.
They celebrate money when you die.
What?
A bunch of fucking assholes.
That's what people used to do when there
was no internet.
Get away with doing shit like that.
No one knew about it for.
That's right.
Yeah.
They probably didn't know about it
forever.
Somebody had to probably blow the
whistle while they was a good student
newspaper in boston at bu,
but you had a great paper.
It was one of the best ones In the
country and they cracked the case and
they also were very political.
We protested against apartheid and then
they wouldn't allow.
They wouldn't allow opposite sex
students to sleep in the in somebody's
room,
but they had no overnight policy at bu
like in fucking 1989.
Really?
So there was protests about that,
which is also really fucking weird
because what about gay people?
Woo.
Right.
They can just bang it up.
They can pay.
The guys can literally fuck each other
in the ass.
No problem.
Hang it up.
You know,
probably a few problems wIth a few
problems.
Hemorrhoids.
And remember when you used to get the
girl that had a,
a dorm used to find the time where her
roommate agreed to be out of the room so
you fuck right,
or you would come back into the room
after the roommate fucked and it just
smelled like a fucking wall
asshole.
Like cheeses.
No ventilation window done in this room.
That that's true.
All the other smells.
The smell with first.
Well,
yeah,
because nobody.
Look,
if you're not using a bid day,
people were wiping their ass and back
then no one even shaved girls had
asshole hair standard.
It was standard.
You'd find dingleberry's on girls all
the time.
Right?
People just smudge that shit after.
After they poop,
they smudge.
That shit smudge it around.
Yeah.
And then when you're fucking,
you're sweating and pounding and the
grease from your sweat gets in her ass.
Crack and shit goes down through the
taint into her asshole swishes around
with the,
uh,
with the shit stain and what each pump
of your hips,
your wafting smells through the air.
And it permeates the atmosphere.
It sticks to the curtains and think
about it.
It's like a fireplace.
Bellows furnace is a furnace and You're
fucking pumping air onto shit and pussy.
Boy,
there's
no windows.
the room is like a jail cell.
It's like eight by 10 and the dude
probably smells like shit too.
They probably both small.
Terrible.
So he's sweating his ass.
Hold dirty too.
He's probably even dirtier is
absolutely,
probably a more of a disaster area.
It's probably hammer here.
Right.
So as he sweat and his sweats going on
the crack of his ass and yeah,
that's all wafting in the room as well,
right?
Air fucking arm pits.
Yeah,
that was intense.
Man.
Was some intense smells
back then.
And then you didn't clean your sheets
suppressing in january?
No.
May.
There was no mother you.
I cleaned.
Right.
Here's what,
here's my laundry cycle.
In college I had 30 pairs of underwear,
30 t shirts,
30 pairs of socks,
one pair of sheets and once a month I
went downstairs and I shoved all that
shit into the fucking oversize washing
machine and I was done and if those
sheets got come on him,
which they did joe rogan on a regular
basis,
they stayed that way.
They stayed cake.
The that was like the sheet at a fucking
jack shack at seven Pm full of dna.
Ari shaffir didn't change his sheets
for six months as an adult,
aS an adult when he was working at the
store.
Why did want to lazy?
Never cleaned his room,
his,
his apartment was a disaster and then
one day he smartened up and just cleaned
the whole place out.
Wow.
Yeah.
Now he's a neat freak.
I realized I stayed in his apartment in
New York.
It was fucking nice.
Yeah.
He realized,
look,
arusha fears of smart dude.
He's a smart dude.
He bounces back,
figure shit out,
figures shit out.
He bounces back.
You know,
he's been off the grid for three months
now.
Nobody knows where he is.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
there's pictures of him in Vietnam.
Some people have found them in Vietnam.
They took pictures with them and they
put it online.
No shit.
Yup.
He shut off his phone.
Doesn't accept incoming calls.
He is not answering emails.
He told comedy central,
fuck you.
I'm disappearing for three months to
laws.
Friends told us,
hey,
see you guys in a few months.
I don't know how long it's going to go.
Have fun.
He goes,
I just Want to disconnect.
So it just completely disconnected.
He's been traveling.
How long ago was this?
Three months ago.
He did a podcast with Henry Rollins.
This is where he fucked up.
I did a podcast with Henry Rollins.
Henry rollins is a fascinating guy.
Fascinating guy.
Angry motherfucker.
He's very angry.
Yeah.
But when you talked to him and you get
to know his story,
all the pieces sort of fall into place.
He was one of the earliest,
um,
children that they put on prozac or
ritalin,
excuse me,
ritalin.
They put him on ritalin,
which is speed when he was really young,
like five.
And so he would talk about how he'd go
to school,
just white knuckling until the ritalin
were off.
The ritalin would wear off,
like at the end of the day,
we finally calmed down.
So his whole life he was just like
jacked up on speed.
Like his development cycle was kinda
like impaired,
but jacked up on speed in my opinion.
The way he describes it,
I understand how.
I don't know.
There's not a rational argument to me
that they wouldn't have any significant
impact on his life being on speed all
throughout his childhood years until he
discovered exercise,
start to exercise in high school.
Then he slowly got off the ritalin and
all that stuff,
but so he's developmentally like that
was challenGed in a lot of ways,
but he's a fascinating guy,
man.
He just picks a spot on a map like bali.
Okay,
let's go see boli.
Henry rollins.
Yeah,
by himself.
He just goes there,
brings a laptop so you can write,
brings cameras.
We can take pictures and writes now
and just does that.
Travels all over the world.
Just goes to all these different places.
He goes and hangs out with bedouins in
the desert.
He goes,
listens to weird,
crazy music.
These people are making and sweared
culture so just shows up and africa
shows up in all these different places.
Just goes there,
flies in.
So ari has them on his podcast and I
think our.
I was so compelled by the idea of just
completely this picking a spot and going
that are.
He decided for his.
Because you.
He's like super cognizant about africa
does a special.
Like he needs more material.
So what he does is he filmed a special,
filmed it,
edited it,
and then disappeared and then just
vanished for like three months as of
right now,
three months.
And what's your theory on where he is?
I don't have one.
I'm gonna wait,
I'm gonna wait until he comes back and
then I'm going to talk to them,
see what's up.
And he might not even want to talk about
it.
You know what I mean?
He's such a,
he's such an interesting guy.
He might just decide how a good time you
don't want to talk about it.
And that'd be like,
right.
You know,
and maybe he'll decide that the great
experiences would best be reserved for
the stage.
Like he met.
He might have like cultivated some
really good experiences.
He wants to only get about on stage.
He's a weird guy,
but in the best
way,
in the best way.
I mean,
there's a sense of fairness about him
also,
like I remember because I did his show
last season and we did rehearsal for it
at the comedy store in the belly room
and all of a sudden you get this fucking
nice check
and it's like,
oh no,
our,
he wanted all you guys to split this
money and then I did another show from
somewhere else and it was like,
I'm just like,
yeah,
you do the same thing.
but he does it to a point where it's
like he's very aware of being as fair as
possible.
So like when we did his tv show,
he gave us all a gift.
I won't say what it was,
but uh,
it was illegal and every single person
and it was expensive and every single
person got this gift.
Like he's very thoughtful about that
kind of shit.
Yeah.
He's just an awesome guy.
When I met him,
he was an open miker raw open miker just
started,
right?
Young guy just got the store working as
a doorman.
And then one day I was supposed to take
Mike Young with me and Mike Young was
doing the road with me a little bit and
michael and couldn't make it.
So uh,
I took ari and he had never really been
paid before.
You know,
it never really done.
Like,
I think he'd gone out with paulie,
done some shows,
have poly,
but I dunno,
I could never.
He,
I think I brought her to the comedy
works in denver.
You crushed while I was on stage
crushing.
I hold the phone up for Mike Young.
I go,
you fucked up mike.
listen.
And aria was onstage kill.
And he's like,
no,
no.
And I hung up on him because you fucked
up red.
Red is my new guy.
So he's just,
it was just cool knowing him to,
as an open mic or like knowing him as a
guy who just started out and now seeing
him as a guy with a television show,
a successful podcast,
but even more important,
a truly independent
thinker.
yeah.
Like he really is independent.
Like he's,
he thinks his own way.
He's not,
he doesn't let anybody influence.
I mean he,
he'll take suggestions so talk to
people.
He's reasonable,
but he has an idea like what he wants to
do with his life and he's just doing it.
Just a fucking super smart dude.
Yeah.
How?
I thought it was in New York has bumped
because I'm going to be in the,
in New York for this might be.
He might be by now.
Yeah.
I mean when he reemerged as he may end
up in New York.
I get this feeling.
I'm sure one day I'll just get her
what's up?
faggot text out of nowhere and I'm like,
oh,
he's back.
Yeah.
God,
that's weird.
I had no idea it was that long.
I heard he was away,
but I know it's three months.
Yeah.
He's freaking everybody out.
Dunkin's like,
dude,
what do I do?
I don't know where he is.
Like dunkin stay in his apartment in New
York.
How he is.
He's like,
man,
I was supposed to be back a month ago.
What do I do?
like,
I don't know man.
I'm just going to accept it.
Hopefully he's not dead.
So is dunkin going to stay in New York
when he gets back?
I believe so.
I believe dunkin likes it there.
He's been dOing a lot of standup there.
He's been traveling,
doing all this crashing show from may
until auGust in New York.
So I got a,
I got to be in brooklyn the first month
because it's a um,
it's a writing month.
We get officers out there and then three
months we'll be shooting all around the
city and wherever.
So if anybody has an aparTment for me in
New York,
june,
july and august,
I'll fucking take it.
Can I announce a couple of dates?
Yeah.
Alright.
Do you like old school radio guy coming
up?
Does that make sense?
And plugs.
We're going to be fed
philadelphia,
helium,
april 27 slash 29.
That's a good club,
right?
The best clubs ever.
Twenty seven through 29.
And then here's one I think you liked
just as much,
if not more.
Denver comedy works May 4th through the
sixth.
My number one,
not number one.
It's the right up there with the ice
house.
Have fucking happy.
Am I right now?
That's good.
Good.
You got two good fucking bangers and our
other fellow and then mohegan sun in
Connecticut.
May 11,
2013.
Do that.
Don't turn your thumb down either.
Just don't do it.
Connecticut gets so mad.
Brooklyn the bauhaus.
June third.
You ever play the bell house in brooklyn
spot?
Yeah,
it's supposed to be great.
That's it.
I haven't played club.
Ever should get there.
I used to do.
There was a comedy club in brooklyn back
in the day.
There was a comedy club in bensonhurst.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
What the fuck was that?
Was it it next to a gym?
Like a big meathead?
probably.
I think it was the member of the one in
the one that dice started out pips.
Mr. Pip sip system or I think it was
just pips.
Mr pepper is the drink,
right?
Yeah.
Pips in brooklyn.
Yeah,
that's joey cola told me he was on stage
there and a guy showed him his gun,
said he's onstage.
That guy's heckling him and he's like a
mob guy and these guys will just look
at.
I'm going,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
And joe.
He's like,
hey,
what's your fucking problem?
And the guy pulls his jag inside and
shows him a gun like god,
jesus and the club wouldn't do nothing.
Just had to tell,
tell your jokes.
And I had a damn.
That's a.
That's a distracted second half you're
set.
You're not thinking about much else
except that gun.
You're getting through it.
So you're doing.
You ain't getting any laughs.
Alright.
Okay.
I just started to fuck your life up and
he might kill you.
Yeah,
there's a lot of those guys.
did you ever read murder machine?
Now?
Murder machine is about roy de mayo,
who is a famous hitman murdeRer,
capo.
Fucking character in the mob.
People were like mob store.
Probably mad at me right now,
but it's a book that joey diaz gave me
and it's.
You can't put it down.
You start reading it.
It's all about how horrific this fucking
guy was and how many people he killed
his man come with something like that,
but he worked.
He was a mob guy himself.
He had a bar that was downstairs and
above the bar,
that apartment,
and they killed people in the apartment
and caught him up in the tub and they
killed hundreds of people.
No shit just killed.
He killed people for fun telling people
left and right.
It started out.
It was killing people like,
you know,
mob things and someone owed money or
something and they just was killing
people just on the weekends.
Wind didn't trust people.
Start killing them and I don't like the
way you're looking at me dead.
Just killing people.
It's a crazy book,
man.
So can you go to jail?
I don't.
I don't remember.
That's a good question.
See what happened with roy de mayo.
Murder machine was the name of the book.
Joey d is like dog.
You gotta fucking read this.
You've got to read this.
I couldn't put it down.
Unfucking believable and it's just some
fucking complete psychopath and a group
of other sites.
Why is it we can't stop.
Like,
you know,
karen killed.
Gareth has that podcast.
I'm a my favorite murder.
Is that all about murders?
Every week they talk about a different
gruesome murder to class.
Yeah,
it's really good.
But um,
but what is it about us that like I love
the iceman cometh and uh,
there was,
there was another one that was about a
serial killer.
I mean just earlier talking about the,
the angel of death guy.
Like what is it about us that is so
interested in people that take human
life?
Do you think that it's like a part of us
that it's an unexpressed thing?
Like if we were cavemen we would kill,
you know,
I think there's a lot of energy attached
to it,
meaning negative,
negative energy,
but still energy,
like you can't look away.
It's the same reason why you watch like
car accidents or you watch youtube
videos about someone doing a stunt that
goes wrong and they accidentally drive
off a bridge.
Like,
I don't know if you've ever seen the one
with the guy in the wing suit,
tries to buzz a bridge and he calculates
it wrongly,
slams into the bridge.
It sounds like a fucking car accident.
He slammed in the bridge going like,
who knows,
150 miles an hour or something crazy
like that.
It's horrific.
Just fall straight down in the water.
Yeah,
I mean he hit the bridge so hard.
He might've just.
I mean he,
if he didn't have a suit on,
he might have just exploded into like a
ball of jello or something,
you know?
But because he had the suit on and kind
of kept all the blood and body parts in
place.
Yeah,
he hit it so hard.
Dude.
I mean it literally sounds like a,
like a car accident because he's
slamming into the metal of the bridge at
100 fucking whatever miles an hour with
nothing on but a helmet.
Do you regret having seen that?
Like does that in your mind?
Well,
no.
No.
It's not pleasant,
but there's something about those
things.
It's like there's an energy attached.
Oh jesus.
Oh jesus,
boom.
Fuck right.
There's a great.
I'm in a twitter page called hold mY
beer and it's all like,
hold my beer while I lied this firework
off in my mouth.
Hold my beer while I go And pet this
tiger.
one fucking her rafik disaster after
another.
We just like,
what the fuck man.
I like this one.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well it's this one.
Hold my beer while become a rocket
turret.
Watch this guy.
He's got a firebomb and it's facebook.
Just fucking hooks hooks his face.
This one is ridiculous.
why am I being white crowd that glass
musical chair.
It looked like a girl to girl.
Took that dude.
That's fucking great.
WaTch this one.
Hold our beers while we go skateboarding
down this hill.
This one's fucking horrific.
These guys come down the hill and they
just have no way to stop your
skateboard.
It's a little thin lane.
You can't even.
You can't even cut back.
watch this dude.
Ooh son.
Not good.
Okay.
I've seen it's like america's funniest
home videos for grownups.
Exactly,
but I never got into watching the faces
of death and shit like that.
Although a lot of those I think were
fake,
but there are obviously beheadings I've
never.
Have you ever watched a beheading?
You have good.
Yeah.
Don't regret it.
Yeah,
but why do people watch them again?
It's because there's energy attached to
it.
You know there's a consequence of what's
happening.
you're watching something you're gonna
have.
The consequence doesn't really manifest
itself.
Like watching people do balancing acts
on the top of skyscrapers.
Even if you know they survived,
which is how you got the footage in the
first place,
it still freaks you the fuck out.
I can't stop.
You know Kelly Slater,
the surfer,
he sends me those.
He knows like they freaked me out.
So we send each other back and forth
fucked up videos about dudes doing
balancing acts on the side of buildings.
Like what the.
I can't watch those man.
My hands start sweating.
My asshole starts squeezing.
I just go,
what the fuck are you doing?
There's a lot of that shit and Russia
dudes hanging off the sides of buildings
by their fingertips.
You ever see those?
Yes.
Do they do like hanging with one arM?
You know how hard it is to fucking hang
from one arm and to hang from one arm
when you're 700 feet in the air or
something crazy.
It just makes you think how little human
life means in Russia.
Those dudes look,
kill at the drop of a hat.
Alex,
alex honnold.
He's been on the podcast before.
He's insane.
He is so crazy.
He free Solos,
which mean look,
my hands are full.
My hands.
Yeah.
So remind.
Oh yeah.
Sweat to go back to alex.
So,
because these guys are fucking crazy.
Alex is like the number one free solo
guy in the world or at least one of the
number one guys.
And what that means is he doesn't use
ropes.
Yeah.
So he'll map out a,
um,
a climb.
Sometimes we'll map it out and sometimes
it was just a path that you can take and
sometimes we'll map it out with ropes.
But he's like,
you know,
honestly,
even while I'm doing it with the ropes,
I don't really need the ropes.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
And so he does this and he freaks people
out and he freaks out even experienced
climbers.
And there waS a documentary they did
about them where this guy was like an
experienced climber.
It was like,
it's not.
IF he's going to die,
it's a matter of when he's going to die.
Right.
But that's probably a helIcopter taking
his picture or a drone.
Right.
Fucking a man.
If it's a helicopter would probably be
too dangerous.
The breeze from the helicopter would be
super dangerous.
I used to do shit like that.
I got,
I got a picture of me hanging out with
my friends.
Fourth floor balcony badlands.
Nice to do that shit all the time.
Yeah,
to my book.
I got the picture of my book.
Jesus christ.
Dude.
Yeah.
I used to like to freak people out.
Oh my god.
This alex honnold dude.
Sometimes he.
He climbed things that aren't even
straight up and down.
They bend backwards to a certain degree
facing forward hoses.
This girl,
well,
I've seen this.
She's hot as fuck.
The whole video where they went up to
him,
this was,
this girl grabbed the guy's hand and he
held her over the edge.
Yeah.
That girl is so crazy to trust that guy.
He can fuck her forever by the way.
Forever.
Forever for like he owns it.
That's so insane.
Freaks me the fuck out,
but I don't stop.
I can't watch this.
Stop what you're doing.
Freaking me out.
I can't do this and still talk because I
can't.
I can't talk and then do that.
I watched those things have a massive
physical effect on me.
Yeah,
but alex.
Anyway,
he,
he climbed stuff.
It's facing forward so he's literally
hanging straight up and down,
wedging his hands into these cracks and
like moving along and then he's got to
reach in for the powder and powder.
the thing.
He was on the podcast,
he told me the story about how he was
climbing once and he realized when he
was halfway up this mountain and he
forgot his powder.
Oh.
So he gets to these fucking people.
They're also climate and they're on
ropes and he goes,
hey man,
can I borrow your powder?
And the guy's like,
okay,
I think god gives him his powder bag and
then when it got to the top,
he left the powder bag for the dude.
It's insane.
He's insane.
He's climbing.
He does.
He is like,
what did I forget?
I got my fingers.
That's all I need.
Ah,
look.
powder shit.
Well,
those,
what do you call that thing?
the,
that the guy died under the bridge at
bat bat suit or a wingsuit wing suit.
It was a whole thing on,
I don't know if it's hbo sports or 60
minutes about the people that do that.
A friend andy does it.
Oh really?
Our friend and he's a world record
holder,
but the mortality rate is extremely
high.
He took it.
Are
he?
He took two guys off the mountain last
year that died.
Doing it?
Yeah.
He,
he's a maniac.
But he's the.
He's got the longest distance ever.
Someone's ever done one of those fucking
wingsuit?
Yeah.
How far do you go?
Something saying like 30 miles or
something.
Yeah.
And they glide along the sides of cliffs
and shit.
Eighteen miles.
Eighteen miles miles dab with no break.
All you can do is catch you catch a gust
of wind and your fucking toe.
Yeah.
Or you're toast.
Go full screen on this bitch.
This is so insane.
Look a fucking high.
He jumped out of a helicopter.
I don't think that's a helicopter.
I think that's a plane now,
isn't it?
Yeah.
That's a plane.
I think a helicopter be a harder thing
to jump out of.
I'm just guessing because the way the
wind is pressing downward.
Does that make sense?
I don't know.
I don't know shit about what would
happen.
Yeah,
there is a plane.
so he gets up there and he does this all
the fucking time.
He'll like send me pictures because he
knows it freaks me out.
He'll send me pictures of him jumping
off some fucking mountain in Guatemala
or something like look at that is so
insane.
Going 163 miles an hour.
Like Why?
What is this is how we're going to be
dropping our troops into the next step.
Not too many people would be willing to
do it.
Well,
not,
not willing,
rAther capable.
I think you would.
You got to be a special person to be
able to pull off a fucking flying
squirrel suit.
Yeah.
I mean
he ever jumped out of a plane.
No,
you don't want to do it.
Fuck that.
I'd do it.
You should do it.
Then just don't tease me.
Jumping off the mountain is way crazier
when they're just skimming it and
jumping out of a plane where you know
this guy's parachute.
That's cool.
But that's not like these guys on 60
minutes.
They were.
He's the same guy.
The sides of cliffs.
He does it too.
He does that same to.
Oh,
he does that too.
He does the whole thing.
This is just a world record.
This is the furthest distance ever
fucking call that man.
Hey tina,
my friend cam up cam when a skydive,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Fuck that.
Now
I don't like free falling.
I know.
I don't like that feeling like I've been
on bungee cords and it's,
it's pure fucking torture.
You and your drops out on
you.
That doesn't feel good,
but I think it equalizes when you jump
out of a plane,
doesn't it?
I don't know,
but I know that brian,
brian redman,
whose dad used to work with this lady
and the girls always like,
hey,
why don't you go skydiving with us?
He's like,
yeah,
will one day,
one day.
Then one day he gets there on monday.
No,
we're so and so.
You didn't hear her.
She died.
It's really chute.
Didn't open up backup chute.
Didn't open up.
Here comes the ground.
100 60 miles an hour.
Boom.
He does bounce off that fucking ground
and become jello.
Jello,
Oregon.
Six crush to the bottom of your body.
Everything is destroyed.
Yeah.
Might go through a barn or something.
Slammed through a barn,
slamming into some fence posts.
Hundred 60 miles an hour.
Just tears you and a half.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
Fuck yeah.
I don't even like roller coasters
anymore.
we did.
I did a roller coaster two years ago in
Florida at busch gardens if you want to.
If you're into rollercoasters,
disney and universal,
they've got a couple that are good,
but busch gardens is like the red neck
paradise.
It's like,
it's like the guY's the fucking carnies.
They've run these ancient rollercoasters
that are insane,
like the twisting corkscrews,
but there's like 10 of them and they're
fucking.
You go.
You cAn ride every one of them three
times in a day.
It's fuck fucker atlanta.
Drive down to tampa,
go to busch gardens.
But I went and it fucked up my neck too.
To this day I have a bad neck from
spinning around on those fucking
rollercoaster.
I already had a bad neck,
but it tweaked it in a way that I've
never.
I've never come back from.
Well,
the inertia,
when you run those things you've ever
done the what is the one that was a
crazy one at six flags like the x
something or another.
While you go upside down and back and
forth,
you're in,
you're in a harness,
you,
they strap you into this thing and you
flip up and down.
You spin around and you're going on a
rollercoaster.
Yeah,
so you're on a rollercoaster and you're
spinning around.
You get off that thing.
Like what the fuck is wrong with me?
Yeah.
Like I'm getting nauseous.
Just thinking about.
I know my son is friends are into that
shit when you're 16.
It's fucking perfect.
Yeah.
They want to make something happen.
When you're 16,
you want something to take place.
Yeah.
Like come on,
let's go.
Let's go.
I want something to happen here.
That's why I had sex so much when I was
young is I just wanted to do something
that was a goal that you could achieve
and then you could go back and tell your
friends about it.
Yet a story.
I didn't care about the girls.
I hate say that I really didn't care
about the girls.
I didn't have a girlfriend till I was in
college.
I didn't even think about having
friend.
When you first started having sex,
did you not want to do anything else?
All I wanted to do was masturbate and
have sex.
I used to have a joke about it.
Well,
my dad was like,
what happened at baseball?
Oh,
I found this new thing.
I like it.
I'll get better the fuck outta here.
Hitting that stupid ball with a stick
ball.
What do you just.
No chicks out there.
There's no girls that come to baseball
games.
when I got off school,
I'll sit and you're dressed in fucking
dea.
Jordache jeans and you're flaring
airbag.
What happened to baseball?
I found pussy.
Yeah,
like the first,
like slow,
steady,
like all the time,
sex that I got,
I think it was either 16 or 17 and I had
a girlfriend who was a year younger than
me.
And you know why I was nervous about it
because when I turned 18,
people were telling me that I could get
arrested.
It's right because she was oNly 17,
like you get arrested for statutory rape
and I was like,
what?
But a blank.
But we dated before when it was okay,
but it doesn't matter.
You have to stop.
Oh my god.
I was terrified.
I thought I was going to go to jail.
That's crazy.
That means you're 18.
You have to only bang someone your age
or older.
Who.
I'll take it a step further.
I've been talking about this in my act
of like how I still jerk off to like
I'll think about girls from high school
that I went to high school with and I'll
jerk off to them.
I don't know.
And then uh,
I got the yearbook and I looked up this
one girl,
jill,
I won't say her last name and I was
jerking off to her picture and then I
was like,
I was like,
I think this is wrong,
but then I thought no because I used to
jerk off to her before I was an adult,
so maybe I'm grandfathered in.
I would say you are.
I'm grandfathered in,
right?
Yeah.
If you start jerking off to one of your
kids,
17 year old friends.
Yeah.
That's fucked up.
That's fucked.
That's a felony.
No.
if you get pictures,
if I look at a yearbook to like say I
find it 2016 yearbook right from
hollywood high school.
Okay.
I find it at a flea market and I take it
home and I'm jerking off to girls that
are 14,
15,
16 years old.
Is that not kiddie porn?
No,
because there's no pornography and so
100 percent up to your imagination.
It's like if you seen a girl scene,
those varsity field hockey skirts.
No,
I'm not into that.
But if you see a girl walking down the
street and you know,
you think she's on the edge like 17 or
18 and you don't know,
like,
I don't even know.
I'm just going to say she's 19 and she's
just,
you know,
I'm just guessing and then you go beat
off and are you any worse than if you
knew she was 17?
Have you see her?
She's got a big fat ass and big juicy
young titties and she's walking on the
street like,
oh my god,
I can't believe she's only 17.
And then you go home and jerk off tour.
That's different,
right?
Knowing knowing makes it creepy.
yes.
Yes.
Because you're jerking off to the age as
well as the image.
If you're going up to the image,
you're fine.
Yeah.
If you just see the girl walking down
the street and she's like,
god,
what do you think?
Illegal.
It's like if you're gonna shoot a moose,
they have to be 52 inches in Alaska,
which means,
which means the,
uh,
the antlers have to have either a
certain amount of brow tines or they'd
have to be a certain distance apart from
each other.
They want the hunters only to hunt
mature animals that have already bred,
like just the idea of the conservation
aspect
of it to keep the breeding population
strong.
Yeah.
So when you're ready to shoot an animal,
especially if using a rifle,
you have to be really sure.
You have to like,
boy,
I don't know.
I don't know he's coming,
he's coming.
I don't know if he's,
I don't know if he's legal,
but let's back up,
let's back up.
And it happens all the time.
Or guys like fuck.
And then you know,
it turns out it was leak or if it wasn't
legal that's a good thing to shoot it
because even though it's an arbitrary
thing like decide or weird thing,
like trying to decipher whether or not
something is 50 plus inches from 200
yards away.
Like you're just kind of guessing.
And a lot of ways,
yeah,
they,
it's a really important because if you
fuck up and you shoot one that's young,
you're in deep shit it.
Yeah.
So you could just make a mistake and
shoot a bull that's 45 inches.
You're fucked.
He'll lose your license.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're going to have to pay a fine.
You lose the animal.
You won't be able to take the animal
home.
And they check.
Yeah,
they'll check.
Yeah.
And all the meat that you got from that
animal you fucked unless you poach it.
Unless you decided to not tell anybody.
Which people do.
Do they especially do.
If they realize they fucked up,
they fucked up on purpose or they got
delusion with themselves and they shoot
something that's smaller than it should
be.
Like you're in big trouble though when
you do,
depending on the state.
Every state has different regulations.
But that's kinda the same thing with
this 18 year old girl because like some
girls are 19.
They lived with their 15,
like some girls are in their 2015.
Well,
it is weird when you see girls with porn
with pigtails and they pretend to be
just coming home from school and some
guy pulls their pants,
his son and fucks him and comes in their
mouth and it's like,
what am I watching?
And they act like children act like
kids.
They act like young girls.
Yeah.
It's like,
but that's,
you know,
that's a woman playing a role.
You know,
she's over 18,
she's a fully committed adult,
but there's a,
there's some girls that are like 14 and
he was like,
they're 18 that especially when you're
across the street,
you're not close to them.
You don't like catch subtle cues that
you're dealing with a child.
Right.
You know,
there's like weird,
like a lot of girls in particular are
full grown by the time you're like 15,
you know,
like there,
that's as tall as they're ever going to
get.
Whereas boys keep growing a little bit
longer.
I grew in college.
Yeah.
They say girls after they have their
periods stop growing or that makes sense
and stopping pleasant.
You know,
if I,
if I'm at the beach,
if I'm at the beach and I see a girl and
she's with a girl that I can tell is
under 18,
but she doesn't look under 18,
I won't look at her just out of fear
that she must be under 18 because you
don't want to put her in this bank bank.
She's got to stay out of the spank bank.
She's.
Yeah,
I put aI.
put a yellow tag on her.
Very ethical.
Well,
it's hard because once you have kids
that are teenagers,
it's fucking scary.
It's like,
you know,
my fucking son is 16 years old,
but let's admit that that is a gray
area.
Yeah.
who knows?
That could be the older sister,
you know,
it could be one girl and her older
sister,
like she might be 19 friend,
might
be 17.
She could be a 51 point buck.
She could be bull bull,
bull moose,
51 inch block.
Jesus christ.
You've got to kill that thing.
what's the youngest girl you ever had
sex with when you were a teenager?
I was,
I think I was 16.
My girlfriend was 15 and she was the
first girl I ever had sex with,
so that was the youngest.
Who's 15 years.
She's 15 now.
16.
Yeah.
I came instantly.
As soon as it touched it,
I was like,
what?
What happened?
The first time I ever came was blow job.
I never beat off and there were serious.
For real.
That must have been the greatest blue.
Jay paul ties dab and chasing that
dragon.
Yes.
My ears rang.
I'll never forget.
It was on the porch,
the front porch of my girlfriend's
house.
Her mom was upstairs,
so she blew me on the porch.
No shit.
Yeah.
Had she blown a guy before,
I'm sure seems like it.
If she's on the front porch.
She has been around a couple of cox.
She actually had sex with one of my
friends before she had sex with me and
my friend was like a,
a real weird.
He was like a city guy where I was like,
we were living in the suburbs.
My friend was my friend actually before
I knew her from back when I lived in
Jamaica plain and he was always a really
weird guy.
He was like one of those guys that would
wear those black reebok's with the
velcro.
Yeah,
like the,
like the aerobic shoes.
And then he had cavalry cheese,
like you dressed well back then that was
dressing well and I always felt like
super insecure.
I'm like,
wow.
She dated that guy.
That guy was like street smart and you
know,
like he kinda like,
he was like,
he was hip smokes cigarettes.
He knew how to dance.
He could dance like music speakers are
speakers.
Who was just a weird guy.
He was a really weird guy.
Was he a guido?
No,
no,
I don't think he was italian.
He was,
I don't remember what he was,
some non distinct european lineage.
But uh,
she banked him and then that didn't work
out.
She actually made out with him once at
my house the first time.
But was like,
when your kids,
we played spin the bottle I'll make out
with each other and we didn't know what
the fuck we're doing.
We couldn't even believe that we make,
we can make out with each other.
Like,
wow,
this is amazing,
you know.
So wait.
So you get the blow job.
You've never had a hand job,
you've never jerked off?
Nope.
Why did you never took off?
Um,
I didn't.
I didn't know that it would be like that
worth doing.
Like I didn't jerk off until after I was
having sex,
believe it or not.
And this was when you were,
what?
15 at this point?
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yeah.
15 or 16 maybe.
Maybe 16 because I had sex.
I,
I'm pretty sure I had sex.
I think it was like,
right when I was 16.
She was 15.
That's when we actually had sex.
She mIght have blown me before I was 16.
But anyway,
um,
my ears rang.
I couldn't believe it.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Like I came so hard.
It was this reward system that like the
universe and biology,
it's set up this crazy reward system to
try to get you to breed.
It's really interesting because when
you're at your least responsible,
your least developed.
Your brain is mush.
Brain was useless when I was 15 years
old.
I had a monkey's brain and it was this
just ridiculous,
silly brain.
No way did I have any like sense of
responsibility or how to take care of a
kid.
Like impossible.
Yeah.
I didn't even have my own shit even
remotely together and my body wanted me
to have a baby.
You wanted to trick me.
I was horny all the time,
like ruthlessly horny,
you know,
and after that girl gave me a blow job,
then we want to be in boyfriend and
girlfriend having sex all the time.
We just fucked constantly.
Kind of just.
Oh,
maybe twice.
that's crazy.
Yeah,
definitely not smart because back then
you're not dribbling out of load.
You are fucking rock it deep into the
cervix and rethread you're trying to
pull out.
So guests,
I guess somehow or another pulled it
off.
Wow.
You got lucky or she had a couple of
abortions.
She didn't tell him about the possible a
new,
a lot of girls in an abortion,
so not even with me,
which is like girls in town,
one girl at three of them.
And we're like,
jesus,
honey,
get on the fucking pill.
Yeah,
get on the pill.
Right?
Um,
but my girlfriend in high school got on
the pill and then it was just like,
just rockets right in there.
It'S ridiculous because when you're a
young kid,
like the idea of the pill is a strange
thing,
right?
You're circumventing biology.
You're saying that's not good for the
nature's I know what you're fucking plan
was.
I know what you're trying to do,
but guess what?
No one's ready for this when you were
16.
Okay,
so we're going to give someone the pill.
But for girls it's a terrible deal.
They got to take these fucking wacky
hormones going to take estrogen when
you're 16.
Like what does that do to them?
yeah.
You know,
they say it does.
One of the big things,
it fucks up a woman's ability to
differentiate whether or not cheese
compatible with a guy.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They've done these things where they
take women and they'll have them smell a
guy's clothes,
clothes that a guy wore and they can
decide and they can just pick from the
smell whether or not they would be
compatible with that guy.
It turns out they're really good at
picking whether or not they're
genetically compatible with that guy.
Wow.
But that gets totally monkey wrench into
the gears as soon as they get on the
pill,
when they get on the pill that their
sense of smell doesn't work anymore like
that.
That sort of weird primate instinct.
The animal instincts of being able to
smell whether or not the guys compatible
with you.
It doesn't work anymore.
Dude,
I knows rape this girl at the gym.
Yesterday I was on the treadmill and she
was next to me and she had long black
hair
and she tussled it up and put it into a
bun and whatever conditioner she had was
floating over.
Then she started running.
She was this persian girl in the armpits
were fucking emitting.
I was running with my head at a 45
degree angle.
Inhaling through my nose exhaling to my
mouth.
Just knows raping her.
Did you have a plan?
If she said,
why are you leaning towards me?
tell her about the rollercoaster.
You can Tell her about.
Listen,
I got.
I gotta to tell you.
I will tell you the story.
It's Crazy.
Long story.
Do you have time?
I'll buy you a cup of coffee.
Can we just stand a little closer to
this position?
gardens.
Tampa fucked my neck up on a
rollercoaster.
It's the craziest roller coaster.
She forgets her sweatshirt.
I'm down to the men's room.
Just fucking.
I mean she had.
She was hot.
She was running.
I usually run with the Iran at a six
point two miles an hour,
which is pretty slow,
But it keeps my heart rate at 1:35,
which I need to do for like 40 minutes
straight.
She was running at fucking eight point
five miles an hour,
which is pretty goddamn fast because she
was small and a nice,
nice tan,
little persian legs,
but the smell of fucking unibrow,
she was a little gland.
She was a gland.
It was coming out.
It was coming up from the undercarriage
everywhere and I'm just running and I'm
trying to.
It was like a.
It was like a powdery flowery thing
mixed with a pit stink.
Those are the girls,
like a really sexy persian girls are,
I guess you would say iranian if you
weren't being politically correct.
Hilarious.
They call them till persian.
Yeah.
That's what a purchase since like 1930.
Right.
Mike,
let's just call ourselves africans.
Yeah.
Because we all have to go like,
oh,
you're persian.
Oh,
elaborate.
Introduced my friend.
He's from the ottoman empire and I'm a
hittite.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
but the,
uh,
I Was sitting on a bench one day.
this couple walk past me.
Curl was pretty hot.
Little nose rape.
Take it in nice and small.
I got a very strong,
um,
uh,
what do you call your nose?
Sense of smell?
A factory loan factory.
I got a very strong olfactory sense and
so I was like really enjoying it.
And then,
uh,
about 10 minutes later the guy walks
past me and he smells good too.
That was the smell.
Oh no,
no,
no.
What was he wearing?
Like petroleum or Something?
It was,
it was spicy.
That's one of those things.
It was so off that a girl could pull off
to like both hippie species,
male and female.
Both genders can wear but truly merits
mark marin.
Whereas virtually I don't believe you.
Yes he does.
I might have to find that out.
Grateful dead music and purely oil.
Really?
Where's petula?
Oh,
dairy.
Really?
You sure?
He just fucking with me.
You know,
I,
I'm,
I'm almost 100 percent sure.
Not all the time to start.
He has in the past.
Warren pachulia.
Do you think some girl fucked him at one
point in his life because he was wearing
petrolia and he's like,
look,
just roll the dice.
If a really cancels out,
I don't want that kind of pressure.
Like if a girl doesn't fuck me because
I'm wearing,
but truly I don't want that kind of
pressure.
That's true.
It's a lot of pressure.
Yeah.
That's my argument for the fanny pack.
Well guys like,
oh jeez,
if you murdered,
I'm like,
listen to me,
if I wasn't married I'd be more inclined
to wear it because if a girl won't fuck
you because you wear a fanny pack,
you don't want her to fuck you.
It's too much work.
Yeah.
I love seeing single guys who have that
attitude.
That is the attitude.
You kind of have that attitude.
Otherwise you get distracted and that's
what I learned from beating off.
It's one the things I learned from
beating off when I first started beating
off,
which I told you after I had sex.
Yeah.
I realized like,
oh,
this is what's going on.
I got my little addict,
like I came and I was like,
I don't really need to go out with her.
I think this is not necessary.
Like before I was like,
I got to see here what am I going to see
her when I'm going to use here.
But I wOuld beat off and it would give
me a few hourS of relief and where I
could think clearly.
Right,
Okay.
Just have a bit way back iN the day
about jerk off first.
Then think about it that it should be
like an ethic that men approached their
entire life with some fucking terrible
mistakes you make when you're under the
influence of your own dick.
Because your own dick will talk in all
sorts of stupid situations.
But if you jerk off first,
you know you're not goIng to go into a
barn at 4:00 in the morning with some
crazy girls doing coke.
Like I gotta go like,
yeah,
if you jerked off.
And she's like,
come on,
you're fucking scared.
Like I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Got to go see a your horn.
And you're like,
alright,
let's do this.
Right?
You want me to suck your dick?
Yeah,
you want me to suck your dick?
You got to do some coke with a kid just
doing coke and they can't even get it
up.
You Faggot.
How can we can't get it up?
Faggot doing fucking coke.
I'm supposed to suck your dick.
He not even getting it up.
Sorry.
And it's 4:30 in the morning.
You should never be up at 4:30.
Still trying to get laid.
That's what happens.
You start doing the coke and all sudden
you went to a bar that close,
you went to another book,
you're fucking thrown down.
KaShi.
You haven't even gotten laid yet and
you're still che.
Then she wants to go to denny's and then
you got to go hang out at her house and
she wants to do more coke and then also
at 4:30 in the morning,
it's not.
You don't even give a fuck anymore.
It's like
it's got to happen in the first two
hours and he knows a horrible one for me
in the summer when this would happen and
I had jobs so it'd be like 4:30 in the
morning and I'd be still trying to get
laid and then I had to be up at seven to
go to my construction job.
a oh cb carrying wood all day exhausted.
He didn't shower.
So you get that oil,
he fucking stank and your under
carriage.
Your ball sack is sticking to your
thigh.
I'd come home and fall asleep before he
even got my clothes off.
I just hit the fucking bed sideways.
Out cold.
Yeah.
Wake up in the morning and do it all
over
again.
Oh Yeah.
I used to park cars at a country club
and we would go out all we would get
paid in cash tips.
We'd make a good one,
hundred and 50 bucks in cash.
I was 16,
17 years old.
we go out to the bars,
do shots all night,
get laid.
We go skinny dipping.
There was a pool that we'd break into
and it was a bunch of teenagers that
would all skinny dip on any given night
in the summer if it was hot out,
you go to that pool that was naked
teenagers swimming and you could get
laid pretty easily and then we would go
and then we'd have to be there at 6:00
in the morning to park cars because the
golfers and we get there and we had this
little wooden shack and we'd run up and
down the stairs,
parking these cars because it was down a
hill,
so you'd have to drive it down the hill,
run up,
drive it down the hill for hours,
and then finally they'd all be out on
the golf course kickback in that shack
and just fucking lay on the wooden floor
and sleep for a couple of hours.
Working when you're tired and your kid
is so important,
so important to realize how to power
through things.
You don't power through shit when you're
a little kid.
Maybe they make you take naps.
Quite the opposite of power and through.
Yeah,
like are you tired?
Look,
greg,
just take a nap.
You need to take in that we don't want
to do.
Go take a nap.
Take a nap at school.
Remember that?
These have nap time in school.
Then you'd take a nap when you got home
and then all of a sudden no more naps.
All of a sudden you have to work again.
It happens over the course of like a
couple of years.
Yeah.
Now I got to get up at six.
Those summer jobs.
Those were the big eyeopener for me.
That's when I knew.
That's when I fucking really knew I
could never work instruction.
That's when I really knew like summer
jobs when I was in high school and right
out of high school,
so like,
fuck
yeah,
because I had just true.
You should bust,
you should make your kid bust his ass in
high school so he can realize he needs
an education or you need to pick
something to do young.
I
got to pick Something.
Do different [inaudible].
I had other jobs that weren't as hard.
Like I worked at newport creamery.
I was a dishwasher and then I was a
cook.
Wasn't that hard?
I mean,
it sucked.
It wasn't fun.
Be cooked burgers,
make ice cream sundaes and shit and
milkshakes.
And before that it was the guy wash the
dishes.
I moved up,
gone up bro.
I didn't want to take the waitress job
though too much responsibility to be a
waiter or waitress.
Lipstick a perfectly good good.
And those tights.
But um,
that was my only job that I'd had until
I started doing construction jobs.
Yeah.
My dad's an architect.
My stepdad got me gigs,
he's an architect and he got me gigs in
the summer,
like,
like real jobs.
I was like,
holy shit.
Like when you're a labor,
you're a 16 year old labor on a
construction site.
fuck your life.
Fuck my life every day.
Fuck your life.
And plus I didn't know how to hydrate
back down.
I never drank any water and drank a coke
in the morning and then all day,
no drinking,
whatnot.
No awareness present already.
Sunblock.
Oh,
it was
bronze,
like copper.
and I would just fucking carry shit all
day and be so tired.
But I remember thinking,
okay,
you got,
there's gotta be a fucking plan.
we got to make a plan to avoid this.
Can't be doing this because you guys
that would do this.
My friend leroy got me a job once.
This was a really important turning
point.
He and his friend hank,
they would renovate buildings in
dorchester.
It's real shit neighborhood real bad and
these buildings were like basically like
completely wrecked and they would redo
them.
And this one guy,
he was like semi homeless.
He lived in this place while they were
redoing it and he had a mountain dew
jug,
like a two liter thing of mountain dew
that he filled with malt liquor and he
would just drink this mountain dew jug
of malt liquor all day.
He'd be just blasted all day on the
construction site and we're walking
around.
IT's like exposed beams.
There's a to the left and the right,
there's fiberglass,
you know,
that's an overlap.
Thus you could step through and you just
drop right through the floor below.
and this fucking guy walked like a
ballerina drunk as fuck.
His name is jeff.
Never forget.
Jeff walked around this,
this construction site and just barely
not stepping on nails,
just barely and drunk and hammered and
everybody knew it.
Shakes his hands would shake,
just hold the mountain leader,
the two liter mountain dew thing and you
fucking shake and while he's trying to
drink a full on alkie and you were like,
that's my future.
I didn't think it was my future,
but I knew it could be a future if you
did what that guy's like,
whoa.
Yep,
yep.
Yeah.
You realize that.
Uh,
w with.
I had a job,
I was actually in college,
but one summer I went out to the
hamptons,
me and my brother and this other guy
from northern Ireland,
sean,
he was fucking drunk and we shared a
studio apartment fully written.
First two guYs in,
got the foldout caps.
THird guy was on the floor.
So you'd try to fucking get home before
the other guys with fleas.
Fleas all summer.
Did you guys have a dog?
Did someone have a dog now?
Somebody must have had a dog before the
place was infested and I would go down.
My job was I would ride my bike and I
remember it was six miles.
I would ride my bike to the beach and I
had to get there at like 7:00 in the
morning and it was an outdoor beach
club.
It was a bar.
Basically.
Brooklyn would unload and show up at
this place.
It was called summers on dune road in
the hamptons and they had to outdoor
bars that each had six bartenders in it.
Power,
you know,
power pouring,
like fucking tom cruise and cocktail
chicks in bikinis,
bartending and then inside two more bars
with six more bartenders,
speakers the size of a fucking
volkswagen.
So I'd get there at 7:00 AM.
My job was get the fucking dolly and get
10 speakers outside that were all the
size of volkswagens,
plug them in.
First thing was do that.
And then I put on 2001 space odyssey at
nine to clear off all the drunks that
were on the sand from the night before
because you had to pay to get in.
So theY wanted to clear the fucking
beach.
All these people get up screen with
their hands on.
Um,
a shot
and then I would carry up me and the
other guy would carry up racks,
you know,
booze racks with like fucking 15 bottles
in them,
carry them up,
stock each bar for six bartenders,
start bringing up fucking garbage cans
full of ice,
filling up the trust with ice,
bring it up.
Cases of beer,
stuff in the beers into the ice.
I mean.
And then.
And then all of a sudden people started
trickling in around 9:30,
10 cracked the fucking bad disco music,
power pouring in the bikinis.
Guido's showing up.
Chicks that would,
I would have to clean out the bathroom,
the women's bathroom at least three
times a day.
It'd be clogged up with tampons.
These nasty fucking guido chicks from
brooklyn,
which stick their bloody tampons.
And there would be.
And then the men would throw fucking
broken bottles into the urinals.
I'd have to clean those out all day long
up and down.
And the ice was down a flight of stairs
with a broken down shitty ice machine.
And all day long I weighed a hundred and
25 pounds up and down the stairs with
buckets of ice on my shoulder cases.
A coRe is light and just fry and it was
all outside.
So I was getting fried from the sun.
And I'm thinking,
this is great.
I'm going to get laid.
I didn't get a fucking conversation with
one of those chicks all summer long.
All I did was drink miller lites and
then a few times a day I'd run down to
the beach,
dive in the ocean and fucking cool off
come back.
But I made bank.
These bartenders,
they knew I was taking care of them and
they were day.
We're making thousand dollars a day.
Really?
Yeah.
They were making crazy money and they
would all tip me as fucking 15
Bartenders.
All tip and who is three of us,
me and two other guys.
And then I get on my bike at around 6:00
and I pedaled back to our little flea
infested studio apartment and then take
a shower.
And then we go to this place to kill a
murphy's up the street and we'd dance
fucking dance to like,
you know,
rob base and dj eez rock the art of
noise and we and I would break dance and
we'd stay there till two in the morning
and I'd come home and get some more flea
bites,
get up and do it all over again every
day.
I had fleas in my carpet when I was in
high school because of that same dog got
hit by a car and we didn't have fleas
anymore after just died.
I put carpet shit down,
vacuumed it.
But one time I brought this chick home
when I was still living with my parents
and she's one of the chicks that I ever
brought on.
But like I think I was 18 at the time
was still living at home and she was 18
to.
And she knew how to fuck.
Like not just allie,
she was the first girl I ever had sex
with that put her foot on the wall.
It was like pushing off with their foot
on the wall.
Like I lived on the second floor.
And you know,
uh,
some bedrooms have an angled wall where
my bed was,
it was propped up against the side of
the wall,
so it was like a flat wall up to like,
you know,
three feet high.
And then above that there was like this
angle and this chick put our foot on the
top of that.
And she was like,
fucking up and pushed back.
Yeah.
I remember thinking jesus,
like respect.
Like she wasn't just taking it.
She was,
she was given it back from the bottom.
And I was like,
I've never dated a girl did that before
because you know,
when you're 16 you're dating 16 year
olds,
17 year by the time you're 18 girls been
fucking for awhile.
They know what they're doing,
you know?
Yeah.
I remember he had been around that age.
I remember this girl,
linda,
I won't say her last name,
she reached down.
I'm fucking her.
and she reaches down and starts rubbing
her clit.
And I was like,
whoa.
I was like,
wow,
this is about your orgasm,
isn't it?
Huh?
That's a girls ready to party.
Because when you.
There's a certain age where it goes from
becoming about your orgasm to being
about hers,
you know,
and that's,
that's a big,
big,
big primordial change.
There's also like this thing where girls
doing that in front of you,
there's something really hot
about it.
Like she wants you to fuck her while
she's masturbating and looking at you
and like letting you know that she's
masturbating like whoa,
it's full surrender.
Yeah.
But this girl that pushed off against
the wall,
she got flea bites,
overlooked my fucking my carpet and
fucking fleas on it.
And she was like,
what the fuck?
I was like,
ah.
I gotta do something about it.
some mattamy.
I used to have like little bites all
over my fucking ankles all the time.
Yeah,
just thing you had,
if you had a dog back then you know,
like we take some powder,
a spray or sprinkle some fucking powder
and then vacuum is supposed to kill the
fleas never killed most of them.
There's a few gangster fleas.
It would survive.
And your dog would always get them.
They go outside,
they're just get fleas.
Did he have you had those bugs right now
because it was so rainy this winter.
We got these.
They look like giant mosquitoes,
but they're like five times as big as
mosquitoes.
Mosquito eaters.
Yeah.
They're all over the mosquito ears,
right?
They always seem to sting you.
They don't seem to sting,
but you open your front door,
man.
They come right in there every night I
got to kill a couple of in the house.
Do they really eat mosquitoes?
I don't know how you would get days.
They're so slow.
I don't know how they would get to a
mosquito.
Maybe the mosquito would be stupid and
be like,
dad,
like,
yeah,
I can give you a hug.
Yeah.
I mean I heard them called that,
but I was thinking the same thing,
like how the fuck are.
They don't.
Crane flies are actually physically
incapable of killing mosquitoes.
The main sustenance
of crane flies is flower nectar.
The nickname mosquito eaters probably
comes to the fact that some larval cream
fleas feed on mosquito larva,
but it also is only occasionally
and those things.
I mean it's the size of Your hand.
They're big.
Yeah,
it's a weird bug.
YeAh,
there's a lot of uh,
and mosquitoes too.
There's a ton of mosquitoes right now.
We got a wet winter.
It's fascinating.
You know what's funny though is people
are so glass half empty.
I've been here so many people go,
wow,
there's going to be a real problem in
the summer when fire season starts.
Got all this bitch.
Can you just enjoy the green hills?
The hills are green.
It looks beautiful.
Yeah.
I hope it keeps.
I hope this place become seattle and
people move.
I hope it rains constantly and they move
la to like the desert move into like
where area 51 is.
This is where we're going to film from
now on.
Guys start filming out there because it
never rains.
Yeah.
I just read this book about the making
of the Panama canal and they talk about,
you know,
when the french,
the french first tried to do it.
They went in in the late 19th century
and they,
you know,
you gotta think technology in the late
19th century.
They didn't have fucking electricity.
They didn't have shit.
They had giant machines and they were
trying to bulldoze a canal through the
most dense tropical jungle that you
could get through and,
and they,
and they lost something like 20 percent
of the people that went down there,
died of malaria and yellow fever,
which are both mosquito borne diseases.
So they go down there and they fight it
out for like 10 years.
They keep sending people down to keep
dying,
keep sending people down to keep dying.
And uh,
and even if you don't die,
you're working 14 hour days in jungle
heat with a fucking,
with a little spade.
And then all of a sudden they'd get a
monster rain and everything you'd
excavated,
there'd be a mudslide.
It would fill it right up again.
They'd start all over.
There were snakes,
there was fucking mountain lions and
they just finally gave up.
Finally,
France just went,
fuck this.
They had bled hundreds of millions of
dollars.
And so and so.
Then the us stepped in.
I go,
we can do it.
So we came in and some guy had realized
that mosquitoes were the problem like
that.
Nobody knew that.
Malaria and yellow fever.
We're mosquito where mosquito born for
whatever reason,
they just thought it was fucking popping
out out of the dirt.
They thought it was like fumes coming
out of the dirt and this guy's like,
no,
it's fucking mosquitoes.
So he came in with a team of like 10
people and they just started in
educating people about how to get rid of
mosquitoes,
which is basically get rid of standing
water.
And so instead of having mud roads,
they poured concrete and uh,
and instead of having open barrels that
people will collect rainwater and they
would put sheets over them and a fucking
god.
That's it.
That's all he had to do to stop.
No deaths from malaria and yellow fever.
After the first couple of years they
started construction.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
They just figured out a
way to stop the mosquitoes from breeding
without poison,
without poison.
That's incredible.
I would have thought they would just
agent orange the fuck out of that place.
Just standing water.
Wow.
Do you know malaria has killed half the
people that have ever died ever?
No shit.
Wow.
Half the people that have ever done ever
in the history of the human race of
dying from malaria and still unabated,
no fucking cure.
My friend.
Justin's got it at three times.
Really?
Where's he live?
Well,
he goes to the Congo,
makes wells for the pygmies,
justin wren.
But if you catch it and you take the
pill right away,
you're fine.
If you get the proper medication,
you will be okay.
But there's a bunch of different strains
of malaria and some of them last a long
time and he's had one strain where he
got it.
He recovered from It and then he got
sick and because he got sick,
the malaria came back,
so he got an unrelated illness without
being around the mosquitoes and malaria
came back and he had to figure it out
that the malaria had made a relapse.
So he's had it three times,
two times from being bitten one time
from a relapse.
So is malaria something that just stays
with you for life?
I think with some cases,
and not just.
Not necessarily for live,
but it can recur over the course of a
certain amount of years.
And then your body eventually gets over
it,
but he was saying that one case of
malaria,
you can have it for as much as 30 years.
Wow.
And dying of it is about as painful as
it gets.
Your brain starts to fucking fry.
You just go crazy.
Your entire body feels like it's made of
acid.
It's brutal.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck.
You know.
And you think about how,
you know,
third world,
we're trying to do good in the world.
Malaria is just number one,
two and three that we should be focusing
on.
Yeah.
There was some work that they were
doing,
um,
kind of want to say somewhere around
California,
someone was doing it where they were
trying to figure out a way to engineer a
mosquito that does not get malaria.
And they were going to release that
mosquito.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I heard about this.
Is that what it was?
Well,
I think it happened with zika virus.
Malaria really kill half the people that
ever lived get the facts.
Did it?
Oh,
it doesn't matter.
It's definitely probably one of the
biggest throughout human history.
But to actually know the actual fact if
it has killed that many people,
it's probably not because it would have
had to kill it at an average of five and
a half million per year.
And for like the last 30 or 40 years,
it's only about two to $3 million.
So that number,
30 or 40 years?
At least 20 percent.
Yeah.
so,
but they don't know.
So where does it come from?
Does any.
There's any site support that this site
tries to debunk it.
We have to be sure that they're not
right.
Because I feel like I read it from a
science paper,
which might not necessarily look.
Look,
we had rob wolf the other day and he
thought that the vomitorium was really.
Some people make mistakes,
but it's a,
it's killed fuck loads of people.
it's just there's a lot of those god
disease.
It scared the shit out of you.
Like remember when the ebola crisis
happened and everybody was panicking
that a bullet made its way to the United
States.
Remember that one lady,
she was a nurse.
She was in quarantine and they,
they tried to keep from quarantine.
She's like,
fuck you.
I'm going shopping.
That's right.
Yeah.
So like,
bitch,
you're quarantined.
I don't Have it.
Well,
this zika thing is not under under
wraps.
They've got it here.
It's down in floridA.
And uh,
I think that they,
I know they were trying to genetically
modify mosquitoes for zika.
Yeah.
I'm a friend of mine.
His wife got pregnant.
It wouldn't,
wouldn't let her go anywhere.
so like we were supposed to go to Hawaii
or maybe Mexico or something like that,
that they were like,
fuck that.
Yeah.
We're not taking any chances.
I'm gonna stay right here while this
kid's born.
Fuck yeah.
Because it,
it's incurable and your kid develops a
tiny head and it's a really creepy.
They don't even know what else happens
because they're,
you know,
the kids that are born from it are only
a few years old at this point.
Fucking crazy disease.
That's so cruel.
So horrible.
There's a guy named Peter Cortez that I,
uh,
interviewed once and he was talking to
me about,
um,
it was for my saifai,
sheila did years back and he was talking
to me about,
um,
jungle diseases like people that have,
you know,
any sort of infestations of parasites
and things like that in the jungle.
And he said it is 100 percent of the
people that lived there.
They have the 100 percent of the people
that live there have something.
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
I went 100 percent.
Does that mean they're living with it or
they're suffering from it?
They're living with it.
I mean,
they might be suffering from it,
but one of them was,
um,
this cat parasite toxoplasma.
Have you ever heard of that?
Oh yeah.
I'm pregnant.
Women are super dangerous for women to
like,
handle cat shit because of it.
You shouldn't touch a litter box or eat
any vegetables in France because they
don't.
Uh,
my friend,
my wife went to France when she was
pregnant and they said that she couldn't
eat cheese because they don't pass her
eyes it out correctly.
And France.
Well,
it makes sense.
They like that raw stinky cheese down
there.
They love that stuff,
they love it,
but it,
um,
it's a weird one because it makes the
rat,
when a rat eats it or rat gets it into
its body,
a rap become sexually attracted to the
smell cat urine to the point where their
dick gets hard and their ball swell up
and they go find the cat and the cat
kills him.
And then the cat relays it to people.
And one of the things it does with
people,
it makes him reckless.
So there's a direct.
There's a guy named Dr. Roberts polsky
at,
uh,
stanford who's done extensive research
on toxoplasma is fucking fascinating.
Guys get some awesome speeches where he
talks about it online,
but one of the things they found when he
was working in the er is a direct
correlation between toxo plasma and
motorcycle accidents.
Like a lot of these people,
they're really people that would come in
and they would have motorcycle
accidents.
They would test them and they would find
out they tested positive for toxo.
$50.
Million people in America tested
positive for toxo plasma brielle yep.
And it,
it affects the way you think,
it affects your judgment and makes you
more impulsive,
makes you more aggressive.
And it might even affect women.
It might make women more promiscuous or
at least make them more um,
sexually submissive.
They don't know.
I mean,
this is just a complete total
speculation,
but they think it might be one of the
reasons why some south american
countries are very macho and the women
are like very sexy.
So why did we win with cats?
Always live alone.
I don't think it's the same,
but those cats never leave the house.
So.
So if you don't have a cat,
you can't catch this.
No,
you can catch it.
You can catch it from the meat of a cow
that eats the cat shit and it's in its
grass.
Like there's a bunch of different ways.
A lot of people currently,
there's probably 50 Million people in
the country that have this currently in
America.
There's 50 million people plus that are
infected with this parasite called
toxoplasmosis.
Should you geT tested for it then?
I probably have it for sure.
I'm scared.
I don't want to get tested because you
have cats,
right?
Yeah.
I'm definitely.
I'm joey diaz has 150,000 fucking cats.
He's for sure.
Got it.
All those crazy cat ladies are guarantee
you they have.
Yeah.
It's a really common thing.
I think in France at one point there was
something like 30 percent of the
population had talked,
so.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's real.
Well,
we have feral cats.
Is that a bacteria then?
It's a parasite.
It's so sort of a parasite that actually
gets its way into your brain because
that's the crazy thing is what I forget
what percentage of your body weight is
bacteria,
but it's staggering nuts.
Charge 15 percent of your body weight is
bacteria.
Yeah.
We're.
We're all you need to the steps.
See how full of shit.
I mean,
first of all,
find out how many people in America have
toxoplasma before we find that
approximately $30.
Million.
Thirty dollars million.
Wow.
It says it's the number.
See bright $50 million.
See if I.
I don't remember that wrong,
right?
50 million people in America have talks
with one of them died.
Oh my god,
I don't think it kills you on a
motorcycle wreck.
Motorcycles.
But [inaudible] was,
um,
he was,
uh,
studying it's effects on people and
trying to figure out like they don't
really know what it does to people.
There's just this correlation between
motorcycle accident.
Another thing that says up to 60 million
people could have it so makes that a
million people just in America,
just in America,
in other countries,
like in some south american countries,
it's very high.
And uh,
you know,
it might've been just something that
people been living with forever.
It's just,
there's some sort of a weird connection
that we have to these organisms.
And in this one it rewires the sexual
reward system of rodin's changes the
reward system.
It makes their dick hard for cat piss so
that they go near the cat.
So they get killed.
So they can transmit it to people
because cats hanging around with people.
I mean,
assuming that that's the,
the chain of events.
Yeah,
fucking a man.
Jesus,
look at that one to three percent of the
body's mass in a 200 pound adults is two
to six pounds of bacteria,
but also play a vital role in human
health.
Wow.
Human body contains trillions of
microorganisms.
Outnumbering human cells by 10 to one,
so three percent of the body's mass,
but they outnumber human cells just
because of the size,
because they're small size.
However,
the micro organisms make up only one to
three percent of the body's mass.
it doesn't make as much of the mass,
but you are outnumbered.
Human cells are outnumbered 10 to one.
That's like if there's every one rap for
every person on a ship and there's 10
people,
think of that.
I mean,
that's a fucking infested rat filled
ship.
Some of the bacteria is good.
Some of it is.
Yeah,
but I'm just saying you're mostly rats.
He feels like.
What does that a ship of people?
Well,
there's some people on it.
It's mostly rats.
I mean,
it's mostly fucking ratchet.
So we are.
I mean,
if you had a 100 people,
a thousand rats on a ship,
which say that's a ship full of people
or ship full of rats.
I say it's a ship full of rats and pour
a bunch of poor fuckers trying to get
some sleep.
Yeah,
we're just bags of bacteria.
We're bags of bacteria and we don't
understand a lot of it because it is.
It's so fucking small and it's
mysterious.
Well,
how about probiotics?
That's how recent is that where people
figured out that you have to take in
healthy bacteria in your body every day?
Two decades,
three decades.
I meAn,
when did you figure that out?
When do people start taking probiotics?
You take them every day,
right?
Yeah.
I'd taken a live form.
I'd like mostly in.
I like to eat either kimchi or
sauerkraut.
I do that and in kombucha drink kombucha
everyday.
How you did stuff.
Oh,
I love it.
Yeah.
I always keep it here too.
If you want one.
Wow.
We always have it here.
I drink that.
The real stuff that you have to have an
id to show the gts kombucha as the shit
because it's over one half of one
percent alcohol and you can't get drunk
but one half to one percent alcohol.
You have to be 21 to buy it.
Oh,
it's that strong over one half of one
percent and it's made out of like dairy,
right?
It's like raw dairy.
No,
no,
no.
That's key for.
That's a different thing you're thinking
of a key for is like a green.
It was green involved to somehow.
I don't understand really how kiefer's
made somebody explained it to me and I
just blanked out,
but it's a fungus.
It's kind of like a fungus.
It's a growth,
some sort of a thing.
Kombucha.
Yeah.
I just didn't make it.
I used to make it really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
When I first came to la,
I actually,
this girl I was dating got me a piece.
She got me like a live organism.
She told me how to do it and you'd get
like a bowl,
like a glass bowl,
like one of the big punch bowls and you
fill the bowl up with sugar and water
and I forget what the other ingredients
are,
but you stirred all in,
make it dissolve and then you put the
fungus in there and then you put it in
the frigerator or you leave it on the
counter.
I don't remember.
What much fungus do you think to leave
it on the counter?
You just put a good chunk.
Yeah.
You know you have like a piece of this
stuff and the longer you let it ferment,
the stronger the kombucha is going to
be.
And then I would take it in.
I would pour it into like this big
bucket and then drink it and I was like,
it's too much of a pain in the ass
because you couldn't buy it anywhere
back then.
The only way you can get it in 1994,
unless you knew some like super hippie
health food store that sold it most of
the time you got it from other people
and I was like,
does this even work?
Like doing what am I even doing?
So it's even good for you.
But I was like,
oh,
she might be right.
Wow.
A kombucha everyday.
everyday,
everyday you have that.
Or sauerkraut or kimchi.
Sauerkraut to.
I love sauerkraut.
Raw sauerkraut,
but kimchis huge,
super high in probiotics.
It's like fermented cabbage.
So it's all like organisms in it.
Yeah,
it's almost shit growing.
My stomach feels distended and somebody
told me that the probiotics can help,
that.
There's probably a lot of bacteria in
there.
It could be.
Would you drink a do take in a lot of
sugar?
Pasta or pasta?
That's sugar unfortunately.
Yeah,
I know and I,
I've tried to take a fucking bagel every
morning and then I try to never have
pasta,
but unfortunately all that fucking
yummy,
delicious shit.
Like every now and then I'll let myself
have like a giant pastrami sub.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
Italian bread,
mustard and swiss cheese and I love it,
but you feel like shit afterwards
because your body has to process all
that sugar.
Right?
All that bread is terrible for you.
So you just eat vegetables and meat for
the most part.
I mean I fuck around.
I don't.
I don't have a totally strict diet.
I have a mostly strict diet.
You eat rice sometimes?
Most of the time,
no,
but sometimes like I'm having sushi.
I'm like,
fuck it,
let's live more.
But if I'm not feeling that,
I'll either appeal the sushi off of the.
Off of the rice have succeeded.
Like sashimi.
Yeah,
but I'll eat like one out of every
three.
I'll eat the rice.
Just gotta.
If you're on a diet where your body's
fat adapted,
if it's burning off fat,
as soon as you tip the scales and you
have too many carbohydrates,
it's like fuck it.
We're going back to carbohydrates.
Then you get tired.
Easy.
You get hungry.
It's like it.
It fucks with the system.
Once you start getting that fat adapted
state and it's hard when you're out to
eat a decent lunch that doesn't have
carbs in it,
everything's a fucking sandwich.
Salads,
salads,
chicken salads and salmon.
Salmon is really good.
It's cutting oils in it.
Healthy oils.
Ask them for olive oil,
pour the olive oil on the salad.
Nothing wrong with balsamic vinegarette
either,
but uh,
you know,
most salad dressings are bullshit.
Yeah.
Most salad dressings,
just nonsense and sugar.
And you drink,
like if you have like a delicious french
dressing,
like why thing?
It's delicious.
It's fucking desert.
Yeah.
You're eating dessert,
dessert,
ketchup that you pour over your salad or
my kid eats fucking granola bars all day
and I'm like,
dude,
that's a candy bar.
Yep.
it's just sugar.
It doesn't seem like.
It seems like you're eating oats and all
healthy and shit.
You just as better off eating a snickers
bar.
Yeah.
Same shit.
I'm kinda.
What about fruit?
Somebody?
Somebody told me that not all fruit is
good to eat because it's got too much
sugar.
Well,
fruIt of today we have to really realize
when everybody's
using these terms.
Gmo,
and this is something I've looked into
pretty heavily and I had this guy kevin
folta on my podcast as a food scientist
and he's kind of explaining while people
have a lot of misguided misconceptions
about gmo foods,
he's like,
essentially everythIng's gmo,
like everything has been in some way or
another modify that you're eating,
whether it's tomatoes that have been
modified to stay on the shelf longer,
whether it's oranges or modified to be
far more juicy and delicious than
they've ever been in the past.
Apples,
they're like,
we're talking about apples was like old.
Somebody else was just talking about
this recently,
who was.
I don't remember if I looked it up.
there are thousands of different apples
that didn't pull it up to that podcast,
but there's only like five now.
Thousands of different.
Was it?
Rob was rob.
Rob.
Hello,
rob.
Rob wolf is a biologist.
I'm pretty is.
What the fuck is his bio?
Bio.
Fucking something.
Some scientists character.
Really smart guy,
but he was explaining that they all used
to be like crab apples.
They'll still be like kind of sour and
you can eat them.
You remember crab apples when you were a
kId.
We throw them at each other,
throw them at cars.
There are little tiny things.
Green and they were salary shit.
You could eat them,
you'd eat them if you're really hungry,
but most of the time you wouldn't eat
them.
Yeah,
that's what apparently with apples used
to be.
Those were wild apples and people if I
just take that and I don't know how they
do it,
but they figured out how to splice
things and change things and selectively
breed certain plants and they came up
with different strains.
That's why corn looks the way it looks.
Old school corn was like the size of a
hobos dick and it was so naughty and
fucked up look and it was like four
inches long.
So it's A little tiny thing.
It tastes the same.
No,
I mean it's a hobos dick.
hobos dicks are weird,
man.
They're so variable.
You never know what you get.
And it could be a recent hobo and be
like,
that guy who punched you.
Just old school,
not blowing veteran.
His dick tastes like battery acid
addict.
That's been through the pacific
southwest for guys just doing nothing
all day and he comes in your mouth.
What do you think that tastes?
Because if they say that like a guide
drinks orange juice has come,
tastes better.
Have you heard that?
Yeah.
Whenever I heard that,
I was like,
how many dicks do you have to suck for
you figure that out.
You can get away from me.
Do you hold it with your fucking
scientist?
He's sucking dick with a lab coat on.
Taking notes.
My asparagus not recommended.
Switching it around in your mouth like
you're a wine connoisseur,
right?
If a guy eats pineapples,
pineapples is cum.
Tastes better,
but conversely,
if you just knew it nothing but smoking
meth,
your loads have to taste like hot death.
Yeah.
And it does.
And it's fucking lumpy.
Pesticide loads.
Tastes like roundup.
It's not good when you have to kill it.
Not much either.
It's like a fuckinG hershey's kiss
swollen.
I had shit,
motherfucker.
Fuck.
She's immediately tripping on meth.
She's out of her mind.
Do you remember when that actor fuck's
his name?
Tom sizemore.
When tom sizemore went off the rails.
Yeah,
and did a porn.
I'm like,
they would play his,
his thing on opie and anthony all the
time because when he was coming he was
like,
oh,
mother fucker,
just a cracked out load.
There's nothing like a car,
like the sound of a man orgasm.
When he knows he's just off the rails is
off the rails on math making a porn.
It was in saving private ryan.
Here he is.
That's his primal as it gets.
It's like the pure id being expressed.
Just fuck it.
Can you play it?
No.
Can't even show you this legal fee to
play the audience.
Show this.
He was a madman.
Wait,
how do you decide which clips here?
Lead to play tit on that,
so yeah,
we can get it away.
Get it off,
get it off,
get off,
get off the screen here on the screen.
I met him a long time ago.
I did a show on vh one called the list.
Yeah.
I remember that.
The host of it,
I got to.
You are the host of the list.
I was a hope,
one of the,
and they wrote,
they rotated,
rotated,
so I think I did two,
maybe three episodes,
but one of them was I got to meet rob
halford.
I got to meet rick james.
James was a macro,
didn't do none of them kids.
He was like,
we were talking about it and one of the
gals from baywatch was on the show as
well,
and she was a mom.
God,
I can't remember her name,
but very,
very pretty girl.
Her name mary to nikki sixx.
No,
I don't think so.
I don'T remember which one she was.
Anyway,
very nice girl.
Gina something or another.
Anyway,
um,
she was,
it came up in some way,
shape or form and she was like,
I don't buy it.
And he's like,
michael didn't do nothing to them.
Kids might go there And do nothing then
that's all bullshit imitation.
I'm asking all bullshit.
And rick james had been out partying all
night.
So when he showed up,
like we were warned that he might not be
able to do it.
Like he got there and they,
you could tell he just been up,
you knoW,
he's like,
I'm,
I'm suffering from some sort of a cold,
so if I can't do this,
I can't do this.
And we were like,
hey man,
do what you can do to do.
But he went down and went out there and
plow through like a trooper.
Wow.
Yeah.
But uh,
he was defended Michael Jackson.
Margaret didn't do nothing but michael,
what's his face?
Tom sizemore came on and he had fucking
slippers on.
He had like,
slippers and fucking bathrobe.
I don't remember what he wore when he
sat down,
but I remember he showed up with
slippers and a bathrobe and he was just
right when he was just going off the
rails right when he was going.
It was supposed be him and val kilmer.
Val kilmer was out partying all night
and then he was with him and he's just
like,
val.
Karen was like,
fuck it,
I'm not going.
So like last val kilmer was going to do
the list.
Yes.
Falcon one was off the rails.
Don't remember when val kilmer got huge
fat and went crazy.
That's right.
He did a play and we did a play for
awhile and it was like,
what the fuck is val kilmer doing?
Party in?
He was just going off.
It was just having fun and it was during
that time,
that size more showed up.
It was a very nice guy.
Super nice guy.
Math.
Huh?
I don't know what he was doing.
Who's doing a bunch of shit,
but then he wound up on celebrity rehab
member.
Uh,
okay.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
Several seasons.
Was he?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
He was on with heidi fleiss.
Like heidi fleiss was like his
girlfriend.
That fucking celebrity rehab show.
Could you iMagine if you try to do that
today?
They don't do it anymore.
Now it's,
you're exploitinG people's.
The worst time you could ever have
someone in front of cameras when they're
at their most vulnerable.
Yeah.
They are recovering from addiction.
Do you don't think that that's an
impediment to recovery and putting them
on camera,
following cameras around them while
they're trying to detox and figure the
fucking life out.
And you're giving them massive amounts
of attention.
You're putting long shooting schedules.
You got lav mics on them and she started
having an affair.
As you encourage it,
when you're supposed to discourage it is
crazy.
It's everything that aa is not.
It's the opposite of anonymous.
You ever hear doug stand helps bid on
it.
Now doug stanhope tortured dr drew
really tortured him and he's 100 percent
right?
Yeah.
Like look,
they allowed that to happen.
Dr. Drew figured like,
look,
I'm a competent doctor.
I'll take care of it.
I'll make sure everything's fine.
At least it'll expose.
Like you could rationalize it,
it will expose to people what it's like
to go through this.
And you see celebrities and movie stars
going through this.
But a lot of it wasn't celebrities and
movie stars.
It was like sorta celebrities like angie
dickinson where there's some guy on the
show with some young guy was in brother.
Oh,
it was ian.
I think so.
I shouldn't say that.
Julia roberts.
Eric roberts was on.
Well as he and he was on for,
for Pot.
It was hilarious.
So fucked up.
This dude's he's got a newspaper out,
he's drinking coffee,
good morning Shakes,
throw shitting themselves,
sweating through the night.
He's like going through zero
withdrawals.
He's literally reading the times over a
cup of coffee with his feet up on the
beach during the ballot booth somewhere
in some serene environment too is like
when you go to these rehabs,
that shit is expensive and it's like a
resort.
You're getting like you're going to do
yoga.
Then you do a meditation.
Maybe you get a fucking massage.
You drinking all like green green
blended drinks and be well.
Who's paying for it?
All the people that didn't have all the
fun partying.
I'm think you're paying for it now for
the state only pays for so much right
now,
but I mean say you say your brother gets
all fucked up.
You sent him to rehab.
You're paying for it.
Oh,
that's the worst.
If you have a brother that's a coke
addict and you have safety,
you have a family and your wife's like,
you're not fucking paid for it,
greg.
Yeah,
he's gotta.
Get his shit together.
The fucking we need that money for
johnny's college.
Yeah.
My brother is the fourth time.
He's gotten fucked up in two years.
And then your wife's like,
let's just kill him.
Let's just kill them.
You know,
you're probably some fucking loser.
I want to kill him.
Let's take him to boston university life
insuranCe.
Not only we get rid of him like a bucks
on the backend.
Rocky brother.
Let's take them fishing club.
Moved ahead.
Throw them in the ocean
godfather style.
How many people have done that?
How many people were killed?
Loved ones I thought were losers just
for a life insurance policy.
Oh,
all the time.
All the time.
Yeah.
I feel like if you could see like the
numbers of how many people have killed
loved ones for money.
Oh my.
Yeah.
I mean they,
that's what that whole a dark internet
is about,
you know,
getting a hitman to take as your
husband.
That's why my.
I got a $1,000,000 insurance policy for
my wife anymore than that.
She fucking wants me gone.
That's a good point.
1 million lets her get.
Get her shit together to show you.
Don't have to pay taxes on that anymore.
That's one thing for the key is you set
up a shell,
liKe we have a shell that it would pay
into.
WhAt I'm thinking is actually
inheritance tax,
inheritance tax.
Like if your kids inherited your money
right there,
like if you left your kids $500,000,
your kids would have to pay off half of
that to the government.
So they really would only get 2:15.
The government uncle sam like.
Yeah,
like my gut.
That's right.
To take my cat.
I like to whip my bake.
Meanwhile trump's right.
He's like,
well this is fucked up because that
money's already been taxed.
LIke somebody earned that money is given
to you as a gift when they die.
Like you shouldn't have to pay.
It's not earned income.
First of all,
it's only over one point $8,000,000 for
a couple.
And my feeling is one point 8 million.
What do you mean that's the.
You don't pay any inheritance tax under
one point $8,000,000.
Yeah.
So to me it feels like the framers of
the constitution had come from europe
where money had been handed down through
generations,
aristocracies useless,
wasteful,
dangerous motherfuckers,
and when they set up the constitution,
they said we need to have an estate tax
to try to keep the money from all ending
up in the hands of a few families and so
I'm all for it.
I think then if you end up with more
than one point $8,000,000 a year,
kids are set as well as their educations
will be set.
That's a down payment on a house and
then let them earn their fucking way.
That's a good point.
Actually.
I never thought about that way.
You know what I didn't think actually
honestly as weird as that or did think
rather than that I have the problem with
is the money's going to go to the
government.
That's the problem is where does the
money go?
Yeah.
It'd be one thing if you had inheritance
tax and it went towards a worthwhile
charity,
like should be able to pick.
You should be able to pick your chair.
Right?
Absolutely.
That's the way to do it.
Well,
instead of giving it to the government
and they spend as they wish,
they didn't even have to have a fucking
receipt.
You don't have to have an audit of what
they do.
Well,
you look at what warren buffett is doing
now,
he's giving it away before he dies.
That's what you gotta do.
If you want to control where it goes,
give it away.
Save a couple million because that's
what your kids will get and fucking give
the rest away the way you wanT to.
He's basically given it all away.
Ninety nine percent of it.
That's so insane.
This documentary about him.
That's really crazy.
I mean this guy like he literally lives
in the same house he bought when he
first moved to omaha,
Nebraska.
And how's that possible?
Like how?
Who watches his house?
like people must want to kidnap him all
the time.
He stays right there on the street.
They'd fucking show a picture of it
because you have like guards.
No,
come on.
He drives to the same mcdonald's every
morning does he?
And he either gets an egg mcmuffin with
sausage and the egg mcmuffin with bacon
depending on as the stock market is up
or down.
Oh jesus.
And he.
He knows the exact.
He goes,
It's a dollar 68.
I have that exact amount of money.
He's fucking nuts.
He's like really?
Just flies commercial.
Yeah,
he takes coach seats were I think sell
jesus christ.
drives a fucking car.
It's,
I dunno,
there's an old,
but it's like nothing.
It's enough in car.
Maybe people don't believe he's that
rich and that's why they don't rob him.
I think he's like the fifth richest
person in the world or something.
Well,
I think public person.
I think the real issue is like those
saudi arabian arab prince dudes don't
have to report their income.
I'll make that oil cash son.
Yeah.
Make that deep oil cash.
Send their kids to New York city.
They're live in fucking five floors of
an apartment building.
What was the thing you were telling me
before the race?
Before the podcast started about erik
prince,
who used to be the head of blackwater.
There's some new store that just broke
out about the United Arab Emirates.
Oh,
right.
I'm arranging some sort of thing when
they were setting up,
so some,
some back what they call backwater
communication between trump and a major
russian official who's got close tieS to
putin and the black water guy who was
orchestrating the deal.
It'S in a.
it's in the waShington post right now.
And it's saying it happened on july.
Fake news had happened the first week of
january,
right before,
right before he took office.
Yes.
Back channel in some island.
The specialists islands.
So they met there.
Yeah.
So who met someone from the
administration?
This guy,
Eric Prince.
Right.
Who's the founder of blackwater,
doeS not get much more evil than that.
Well,
he had,
they changed the name to something else
and then he moved to,
I think the United Arab Emirates.
I was shamed like the security guy for
the united arab emirateS.
Uh,
yeah.
they're like essentially have their own
army of high level mercenaries.
They were meeting and to explore whether
Russia could be persuaded to curtail its
relationship with Iran,
including in Syria.
I think what happened with the Eric
Prince guy is that once The arab spring
shit started going down,
some of those super rich guys are like,
uh,
yeah,
it's uh,
it's fucking not,
have this happen over here.
Yeah,
let's,
let's put together a serious strategy.
And so they went with that guy.
Wow.
So much.
So much money.
Well,
who knows how much money they have that
someone told me they have trillions,
but I don't know if that is that
documented.
I don't know what's the richest person
in the world is not like the richest
public person,
like the richest public person used to
be bill gates and then with some
mexican,
a telecom guy.
Yeah,
I remember that dude.
Yeah.
But it's also,
um,
it's,
I think the money iS spread out through
these royal families and none of the
money goes to the saudis.
You know,
the,
the citizens now they don't get any of
it.
There's these rural families that have
fucking hundreds of members and the
money all gets filtered throughout the
family.
Crazy.
And they each have nine kids.
And what's crazy is that that didn't use
to be the case too.
Like what the fifties or sixties,
like whenever they establish these,
these emPires,
is that right kind of money.
They weren't getting oil out of there.
Once they started getting oil out of
there,
they just debt like you ever seen the
growth of dubai over the past 30 years?
Like a timelapse images of the growth.
The islands.
Sandbars make Ireland.
Yeah.
They make their own islands and they
have an ocean break to stop.
The islands were getting swamped,
but one of the major does a huge high
rise on one of the islands.
It just sank like five feet into the
fucking sand.
Oh my god.
They built a high rise on sand.
Yeah.
I just keep sinking.
It's going to go lease leaning tower
pieces.
What do they do?
TaMales.
Shit.
You know they bring girls from the us
over.
They're hollow from Russia.
They say you want it from Russia.
but I hear,
I hear stories about us girls to go with
it and get that paper.
They think they're going to go get a
little a paper going to date.
One guy.
You're going to date a whole family.
Will you ever heard what the Salt number
nine,
how he used to rock it now?
he used to have a disco in his house and
he would pay these girls extraordinary
amounts of money.
Stay there for months at a time.
He'd have like 50 of them there and he
would just come down and go,
you,
let's do it.
And he would just come down the disco
just fucking slide down the railing and
his gold underwear and just start
dancing last,
pick one and throw the dick to her and
then go,
I'll see you in a week or so.
And then they would just stick around
and do whatever they had to do.
They'd go to the gym,
workout,
get their toes done,
and he'd pick a new one all the time.
Wow.
He just had so much money.
He just.
One prostitute was like,
he,
that's not good enough.
Yeah.
I want girls who are not prostitutes to
Become prostitutes.
Yeah.
So he just went deep.
What about melania trump?
How dare you?
That's the first landing son of a bitch.
It's equal pay day,
bro.
She's going To have the equal pay.
When she divorced,
she's waiting to divorce that
motherfucker.
you know that she doesn't even want to
live with them.
She doesn't want to live with him.
Listen,
our son,
he's only 10.
Can't kick him out of the school.
He's got to stay in the school.
10 year olds can't move.
They can't move.
They can't move to Washington to be near
a dad who grabs women's pussies and
admits it or who's the president?
Someone said something really funny.
I forget who it was.
they said,
is that the first lady or is that a
flight attendant on the first flight to
mars?
Yeah,
she's a.
She's living with a lot of mixed
feelings.
Looking a ring that fucking ring could
lord.
She grew up in a fucking mud town in
eastern europe.
To that ring is insane.
That ring is like,
how much does that ring worth?
let's,
I guess let's say you guys,
because I'm sure it's on the internet.
I would say her ring is worth $5,000,000
with 20.
Really $20,000,000.
Find out.
Find out young.
Jamie got bold as fuck right there.
I hope you noticed that.
Alyssa milano calls out.
What is she calling out?
Melania trump's giant diamond rings and
official portrait.
Why is he calling out the rings?
What?
C'mon alyssa.
Which she's getting mad at some blood
diamonds.
She didn't.
Is that what it is?
Twenty five to $3,000,000 rang.
I'm so wrong.
What did you pick?
I said five.
It's 25 parents.
Five carat.
So what is milana?
What's her problem?
I can handle it.
I heard melania met donald on fuck
island,
which is one of these islands real.
He had a bring a eastern european women
there and then billionaires shell up and
they all just fuck.
We've got to get richard.
Dude,
you want to go to fuck.
I've got to get an invite.
If it all goes sour,
we're going to block fuck island.
If it all goes wrong,
your wife leaves you mind.
Leaves me with like,
look dude,
I'm not getting any younger.
Yeah,
listen,
who cares what everybody says?
Go fuck island.
Then we start going after awhile.
It's just like,
dude,
what are you doing on tuesday?
You want to go to fuck island?
All right.
He'll go to fuck island,
dude.
We'd be bar backs on fuck islands.
We'd be hoping that they would be able
to click all we have to.
We worked there.
We get a job there.
I'll carry the ice.
You carry the beer.
Come on dude.
We're definitely gonna
duh,
duh.
You and me on fuck island drinking
miller lite on the beach going.
We've got to get out of here.
They took our passports though.
Fuck.
We'd be laying down the real dick
because he's billionaires can't fuck
when these.
When would to be getting horny after
awhile.
Think so these billionaires are
on viagra and meth and they're just
slamming it in.
They probably have helmets on like
exoskeletons and make them fuck harder.
Like some sort of an artificial spine
that connects at the shoulders like a
football outfit.
And you hear the hydraulic while they're
just slamming it in its viagara meth
fueled dick to get a doctor.
That's right.
They're taking vitals at all times.
Like they just have enough viagara so
their their veins pump up so fat and
thick that they almost black out.
It's like a fine line.
You've got to get them to write to the
edge whether they're seeing those here
we get punched and you see stars.
They see those stars while they're
fucking almost going out,
right?
That's what they're doing and then when
they come they just throw them oxygen
mask on him and rub their feet and they
come.
They throw the girl right off the yacht
here spent.
She's like a cartridge and they he's on
the girls were flood because they know
it's coming.
They swim to shore.
They collect their check.
They get on a plane.
They don't say shit.
They don't say,
that's just a day.
Clean out the undercarriage and centered
center.
All of a sudden homegirls go at jaguar,
convertible,
jaguar,
whatever.
I think it's darker than that.
I don't think you leave fuck island.
You just stay.
I think as as the guy is fucking
blasting his last dribble inside of you,
you feel a cold barrel of a handgun on
the back of your head.
Jesus.
Now this is barry on fuck island.
That's it.
I guess if there's countries,
obviously North Korea,
right?
That guy's killing people left and
right.
You can get away with killing people and
certain countries like 100 percent,
like he killed his half brother.
He killed who did kim jong moon.
Oh yeah.
He hired someone To do that and they
apparently they didn't know they were
doing it.
apparently they were doing a prank.
They thought they were doing a prank and
he squirted him with something and it
turned out to be some neurotoxin.
Zapped Him and killed him.
But um,
he killed some guy who was a general.
And then he,
because he thought that it was like his
uncle that he thought was trying to
remember that he killed his kids too
because he didn't want his son's taking
revenge.
So he.
Oh,
that's hard.
So that's going on right now.
If that's going on,
someone could shoot some crazy corrosion
chick on fuck island.
oh yeah.
So she did a documentary on fuck.
Now that's allegedly,
by the way,
just in case the president is listening.
I bet he didn't.
He's an outstanding man.
How do you think he met her?
Perfect grooming.
He met her onj date.
She swiped right.
Is it right?
Right or left?
Swipe right.
He swiped right.
Parties.
Party.
begin.
They met up at a starbucks for a coffee
date first.
Keep it safe.
Oh,
see,
she's upset of the kim jong iun offered
no trace of him behind down
to his hair according to sources in
seoul,
South Korea.
Whoa.
The vice minister of the army was
executed with a mortar round for
reportedly drinking and carousing during
the official mourning period for kim
jong il's death.
Holy shIt.
The vice minister of the army,
they shot him with a mortar round.
This is a different guy.
Holy fuck man.
Tracking and carousing during the
morning period.
Oh my god.
They use an anti aircraft gun falling
the mortar round method.
It seems that kim stepped up his blood
lust a bit with his use of an anti
aircraft gun antiaircraft guns to
annihilate his perceived enemies.
He was anti aircraft guns on people.
No shit.
Yeah.
And on that note,
folks,
it's been wonderful podcast.
Oh,
pew,
uh,
wherever you are,
hope you're happy.
I hope you're happy.
You're not in North Korea.
And if you're in North Korea,
just going learn how to swim tank in
there.
We'll be there soon.
Get to South Korea.
You got to swim.
That'll make the jump.
Greg fitzsimmons coming up soon.
A helium and philly haley would filet
denver comedy works.
And greg with fitstar radio talk radio
is the podcast.
Joe rogan is going to be on soon hollow.
this is probably our best podcasts ever.
This Was good.
Fucking hell yeah.
All right folks,
that's it.
We'll be back tomorrow.
Tomorrow.
Oh,
dan flores.
I'm very excited.
The author,
dan flores,
coyote,
a investigator,
author of coyote America and american
serengeti.
So that should be great.
See you.
Yeah,
that was awesome.